GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
APRIL TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- BECAUSE A QUORUM IS
NOT PRESENT IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE MONITORING HIS
HEARING PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOR
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. DO THE CODE PANDEMIC WE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITH
MODIFIED COMMITTEE PROCEDURES
THOSE WHO ARE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
AT TODAY'S HEARING. AND I SEE A
LOT OF YOU GLAD TO HAVE YOU
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS REQUIRED IN
THE AUDIENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
IS ALSO ENCOURAGED TO WEAR
MASKS. IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH FROM
THE PUBLIC WITHIN OUR TIME
LIMITS WE WILL NOT TOLERATE
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS THE-
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
COMMITTEE'S PROCEEDINGS.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY BE
SUBJECT. TOREMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ELEVEN BILLS ON
ITS AGENDA TODAY. INCLUDING
THREE BILLS ON CONSENT IN ORDER
TO SURE INSURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO COMPLETE
THE BUSINESS AND A LOT OF TIME.
WE ARE LIMITING PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS FOR EACH
BILL. THEY'LL BE A MAXIMUM OF
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT INTO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION WITH A LIMITED TO.
WITNESS AFTER WE HAVE HEARD FROM
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES THE PUBLIC
WILL HAVE. UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
IN TOTAL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ON EACH BILL.
STARTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN THIS ROOM
. OTHER WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT. IF
ANY AND THEIR POSITION ON THE
BILL. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WILL
BE RULED OUT OF ORDER. IF YOU
ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON THE
PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE IS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE-
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF
THIS BILL. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING HIM REMOTELY AND WHO
WISH TO CALL IN TO REGISTER
THEIR POSITION THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR.
FOUR FOUR YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN.
GOING IN PLEASE LIMIT ALL.
WHAT'S THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY. AT
916-319-2090 FOUR. AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. SEED TO OUR AGENDA I
HAVE TO ADDITIONAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TO MAKE TODAY. FIRST THE SPEAKER
HAS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX LIED
TO THE COMMITTEE TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MULLIN FOR
THE PURPOSES OF TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY. SO NORMALLY THERE'S JOINS
. A SECOND WE'RE GOING TO GO A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF FILE ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES. WAS A CONFLICT AND WILL
HAVE TO LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
HEARING- SHORTLY SAID THE
COMMITTEE WILL HEAR AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAYES FIRST. BEFORE MOVING ON TO
OTHER ITEMS ON THE AGENDA WITH
THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE
WAY WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. IT.
WHAT. THE NUMBER GOOD MORNING
MORNING THANK YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY- THANK YOU- CHAIR
BRIAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY ONE AND- MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ACCOMMODATING ME THIS MORNING
I'VE GOT A CHILD CARE ISSUE AT
HOME NEED TO GET BACK HOME TO
TAKE CARE OF MY- ON MY LITTLE
ONE- LAST YEAR- CALIFORNIA WAS
AT RISK OF MAKING A VERY
UNDEMOCRATIC CHOICE. AS THE
RECALL PROCEEDED MANY OF US
PROTESTED THE IDEA THAT THE
LEADER OF THE MOST POPULOUS
STATE THE NATION COULD BE
ELECTED BY LESS THAN A MAJORITY
OF VOTERS THAT WHILE WE AVOIDED
THE WORST OF THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM THAT LEAD US THERE IS
STILL IN PLACE THAT'S WHY WE
INTRODUCED THIS LEGISLATION.
ACTING FUTURE RECALL CANDIDATES
UNDER SYSTEM. THAT ENSURES A
CLEAR WINNER SUPPORTED BY THE
MAJORITY OF VOTERS. THE BEST WAY
TO GUARANTEE ELECTING A
CONSENSUS CANDIDATE IS TO ENSURE
THE NUMBER OF CANDIDATES RUNNING
REPRESENTS A COHORT. OF VIABLE
SERIOUS AN ACTIVE CANDIDATES. OF
THE FIFTY FOUR CANDIDATES WHO
FILED TO FILL THE VACANCY. WOULD
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAVE BEEN
RECALLED. IN MY OPINION ONLY A
HANDFUL WERE SERIOUS THOUGHTFUL
CANCER WOULD HAVE BEEN WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GOVERN AT
THE STATE. THE CURRENT POLITICAL
SYSTEM IS TRANSCANADA'S WHO
FUNDRAISE OFF THE DEFENSIVE
TWEETS WHILE UNDERCUTTING FAITH
AND ARE LIKE TROLLS SYSTEM. THIS
EXIST BECAUSE OUR ELECTORAL
SSTEM IS SET UP TO REWARD THAT
KIND OF BEHAVIOR ONCE YOU GET
RID OF THE ABILITY TO WIN WITH
THE MAJORITY OF THE ELECTORATE
THERE ISN'T AN INCENTIVE TO
ABUSE THE RECALL PROCESS AS WE
SAW LAST YEAR EXTREME CANDIDATES
CAN'T WIN A FAIR RACE IN THE
STATE BUT THE RECALL PROCESS. IS
NOT FAIR. I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED
THAT AMERICA IS. A SHINING CITY
ON A HILL BUT THE TRUTH IS
WHERE. I'M NOT PERFECT- OUR
DEMOCRACY IS NOT PERFECT AND
IT'S OUR OUR JOB- AS ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES BOTH HERE IN THE
STATE- AND- BACK IN. IN
WASHINGTON DC TO WORK TOWARDS. A
MORE PERFECT UNION- IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A SYSTEM. TO GET US
TO OUR PREFERRED CANDIDATE- THAT
IS OUR CHARGE- THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF PEOPLE. WHO HAVE WORKED-
I TIRELESSLY. THE LAST YEAR BUT
FOR. FOR BUT DECADES FRANKLY TO
TRY TO FIX THE SYSTEM OF GOT A
COUPLE OF THEM- WITH ME AT
TODAY. WITH THAT I'LL INTRODUCE
A ROBBIE ROBINETTE THE WITH
BETTER CHOICES DOT VOTE AND CHAD
PEACE WITH THE INDEPENDENT VOTER
PROJECT- HELLO MY NAME IS RAVI
ROBINETTE I'M DIRECTOR OF BETTER
CHOICES ABOUT THAT- GERMAN.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
ONE GROUP FORMS THE RECALL
PROCESS TO PREVENT IT FROM BEING
ABUSED BY FRINGE CANDIDATES THAT
WOULD HAVE NO REAL CHANCE ARE
NORMAL ACTION HYPERPARTISAN
CANDIDATES CAN WIN A CROWD OF
PRO PLAYER OUTING AND THEY KNOW
IT THIS CREATES AN INCENTIVE FOR
THESE CANDIDATES TO ABUSE THE
RECALL PROCESS. AT BEST THIS
WASTE TIME AND ENERGY AND AT
WORST IT CAN ELECT TO GOVERNOR
OPPOSED BY THE MONTH MAJORITY OF
THE POPULATION. WE CHOSE
CONSENSUS ARE INSTEAD OF INSTANT
RUNOFF BECAUSE INSPIRON OFFICE
ALSO VULNERABLE TO MANIPULATION
BY HYPERPARTISAN CANDIDATES.
THEY CAN ALWAYS SQUEEZE OUT OR
BRACKET A MORE REPRESENTATIVE
CANDIDATE. CONSENSYS RCB LOOKS
AT EACH CANDIDATE AND COMPARES
THEM TO EACH OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES IN A ROUND ROBIN
FASHION. THE CANDIDATE. DO WHO
DEFEATS EACH OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES WHEN COMPARED ONE ON
ONE IS THE WINNER. INSTANT RUN
OFF. INSTANT RUN OFF REQUIRES.
ELECTRONIC FORMS OF NEARLY ALL
OF THE BALLOTS IN ORDER TO BEGIN
THE ELIMINATION PROCESS THAT
USES TO DETERMINE THE WINNER. IF
MORE VOTES COMING AT THE
ELIMINATION PROCESS BEGINS
BEFORE MORE VOTES COME IN AS
POSSIBLE TO ALTER. WHO SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED AND RESULT CAN CAUSE
A SIGNIFICANT SHIPS IN THE
OUTCOME. CONSENSYS RCV IS SIMPLY
A SERIES OF TWO CANDIDATE RACES
AS NEW BALLOTS COMMENT THE VOTE
TOTALS IN EACH OF THESE RACES
CONVERGE TO AN OUTCOME CONVERGE
TO RESULT JUST LIKE THEY DO
TODAY. AS THERE'S NO THERE ARE
NO CHEFS IN THE TOTALS AS THE
ROOT ROOT AS- AS THE MORE BUT
CERTAIN COUNTY. CONSENSUS RCV
EXTENDS THE POWER OF THE TWO
CANDIDATE RACE TO A LARGER GROUP
OF CANDIDATES ARE USING RANKED
CHOICE BALLOTS TO DETERMINE THE
WINNER IN ONE ON ONE CONTEST
BETWEEN EACH POSSIBLE PAIR
CANDIDATES. THE CONTENTS AS RCB
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
CANDIDATES BEST STRATEGY.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY PARTICIPATES
IN EVERY DECISION. THE
CANDIDATES MUST REPRESENT ALL OF
THE PLAYERS NOT JUST THEIR
PARTY'S VOTERS AND NOT JUST
THEIR PRIMARY VOTERS. CONSENSUS
DOES NOT MEAN THAT EVERY VOTER
GETS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE CONSENSUS
MEANS THAT THE CANDIDATE WHO
REPRESENTS REPRESENTS ALL OF THE
VOTERS WILL WIN THE ELECTION. I
THINK STATURE. WITH THE CHINESE
. THANK YOU I'M CHAD PIECE LEGAL
ADVISER TO THE INDEPENDENT VOTER
PROJECT FIRST ON THE THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FOR HAVING US TODAY IN
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION AND I
THINK YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK ANY
OF US HAVE A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION THAT RISK COMMITTEES
GET AND BILL I PLATE SHOULD SAY
HEY PASS THIS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WELL. I THINK IT
THAT WE ENGAGE DISCUSSION-
CALIFORNIA IS A YOU KNOW A
BEACON OF DEMOCRACY IN MOST
PLACES ON THE RECALL PROCESS
IT'S NOT AND OUR POSITION IS
THAT THIS BILL IS DELIBERATE
AWFUL AND IT'S A PERFECT PLACE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO START THE
MEASURE HAS AS WERE IN A LOT OF
THESE ESOTERIC DETAILS ABOUT CON
PAPER STEP WILL FIT ALL THOSE
WITH A CALM PATIENTS THAT A LOT
. FORMER HAVE HAVING FOR TWELVE
HOURS. JEFF FOR MY PERSPECTIVE
IT'S A GOOD TIME FOR. YOU TO
WATCH COMMITTEES IN A LOT THIS
LATER TO START. ME ASKING PEOPLE
OUT BEEN IN THE SPACE THE HARD
QUESTIONS ASKING EXPERTS- YOU
KNOW WHY. THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT ARISE YOU SEE IT IN
YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ABOUT
YOU KNOW IMPLEMENTATION AND ALL
THAT THOSE ARE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE SHOULD BE HAVING RIGHT- WE
KNOW THAT. SOMETHING THAT
AFFECTS OUR ELECTION PROCESS
CAN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT CAN'T
BRING IT BACK HERE WE ARE
THROUGH IT IT REQUIRES A LOT OF
DELIBERATIONS SO. YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW NATIONALLY IDPS PROUD TO BE
A PART OF AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
NONPARTISAN REFORMERS. PASSED
THE TOP FOUR RANKED CHOICE
VOTING SYSTEM IN ALASKA OUR
MEMBERSHIP PASSED RANKED CHOICE
VOTING STATEWIDE IN MAINE
THERE'S CURRENT BALLOT
INITIATIVES IN INDIA NEVADA. SO
I'M POINTS. IS THAT. THERE'S A
MOVEMENT AMONG VOTERS TO TRY TO
IMPROVE OUR DEMOCRACY AND- THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IS THE
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO REACH OUT
TO THOSE THAT ARE WORKING ON IT
AND CONSIDER SOLUTIONS THAT
MIGHT NOT. BORROW MIGHT BE TWO
YEARS FOUR YEARS. THIS IS THE
TIME TO START ASKING THE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE- IT IS COMPLEX
AND THEN WHEN YOU DO MAKE
DECISIONS IT HAS A SAID
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT SO- FOR MY V.
P. I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME.
TODAY A PULLEY WE CAN ALL. USE
THIS AS A LAUNCHING BOARD TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT SEEING NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
IS THERE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. AND WHENEVER WE WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON THE BILL. J. MACLEOD
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO STRONG
SUPPORTER OF ELECTION REFORM
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PICTURE.
OPERATOR CAN WE NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE LOCAL FONG WAS
STREWN WITH A STRONGER POSITION
FOR TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE SIX
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'RE GOING FIRST TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE- HAVE WEEKS. ONE FIFTY
ONE HAS DROPPED OUT OF HE ONE
MOMENT WE CLICK STREAMLINED. W.
Q.
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT MR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK
WILL GO CLIMB NUMBER FORTY ONE
FORTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING TURNED HER MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SHARON ALLIANCE THE
REPRESENTATIVE BRADLEY. RUNNING
FOR U. S. SENATE- WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION IN THIS BILL
THE BELIEVE THAT THAT VOTERS
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT. WITHOUT
THANK YOU. THANKS OF ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DON I'M CALLING FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU FOR. MAX'S WINE NUMBER FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GOING UP. HELLO MY
NAME IS HEATHER KELLER PRESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND IT'S ON
THE OPPOSE THE BILL. ONE FORTY
ONE IS GONNA. MY NAME'S MATT
RIGHT THE TONIGHT STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. PICKS UP WAS
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES HELLO GOOD MORNING. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ON THE
BILL. STEPNEY STRELA AND I LONG
OPPOSED THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THIS LITTLE LINE NUMBER FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT
PARTICULARS BARBECUE ONE MOMENT
WE'LL GET THE NEXT ONE. AT ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT WE CAN HEAR YOU
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR TOTAL YOU
KNOW THIS JACK BONTA OF STUDIO
CITY ON THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. OKAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHEROKEE WAS CLEAR.
OPERATOR WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR THAT THE WHOLE QUEUE
. HELLO CUTE- ONCE AGAIN TO
REGISTER SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO RESPONSE FOR
STRUCTURE. COACH DID I ONCE WILL
SLOW WHAT WE DO HAVE ONE COMING
UP OKAY. WE APOLOGIZE FOR IT BUT
ONE NUMBER FORTY FORTY.
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MEGAN I SACRAMENTO BURKE. I
CAN LINE FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. IT IS A FIVE FIVE YES
FIVE FIVE IN CERTAIN YES I THINK
CHESSON ROUNDED CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
FONG SOLUTION. THANK YOU SEEING
NO OTHER WITNESSES WILL NOT TURN
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE- ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT ASSEMBLY MIKLOS-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THIS THIS
CONVERSATION I THINK WE'RE JUST
BEGINNING- THIS THE FEW WEEKS
AGO WE HAD A HEARING HERE WE HAD
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES- WHO HAD
PROPOSED BANNING A RANKED CHOICE
VOTING. IN THIS STATE AND- THAT
THE THAT BILL THAT HE- HAD BUT
PROPOSED A DIDN'T GET A MOTION-
NOT JUST EMOTIONS NOT SECOND BUT
BUT DIDN'T GET HIM. SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS SOME HUNGER- FOR
MAYBE- A SYSTEM THAT IS BETTER
THAN THE ONE THAT WE CURRENTLY.
CURRENTLY HAVE- BUT ALL AGREE
WITH THAT COLLEAGUE OF MINE-
WE'RE TALK ABOUT RANKED CHOICE
VOTING IT CAN SEEM. LIKE IT CAN
BE A LITTLE CONFUSING- BECAUSE
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
THAT WE'VE YET DONE AND JUST
LIKE MIKE. OF THE GENTLEMAN TO.
HEY DAD SUGGESTEDWE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THE MORE
THAT WE- THAT WE- WE SOCIALIZE
THIS WE HAVE A DEBATE. ABOUT IT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
OUR SYSTEM BETTER SOMEONE THANK
YOU FOR- FOR. ALLOWING THIS BILL
TO BE HEARD TODAY AND WILL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU- MISTER MAYES I
THANK. THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
BODY IS OF. THE PEOPLE'S PLACE
FOR PUBLIC DISCUSSION. SO I WANT
TO THANK. THE WITNESSES FOR
COMING IN TESTIFYING THIS
MORNING FOR GETTING THIS
CONVERSATION STARTED. I ALSO
WANT TO WISH YOU THE BEST WITH
YOUR CHILD CARE
RESPONSIBILITIES- AND THANK YOU
JOIN THIS IS ONE. I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FIFTY. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE REST OF THE
AGENDA. THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS. AB SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN MORNING.
THANKS FOR JOINING I THINK THE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTIETH GENERAL ELECTION
NEARLY EIGHTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS CASTOR BALLOTS
MOSTLY BY MAIL WITH THE RECENT
ENACTMENT OF SB THIRTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WILL RECEIVE A
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT FOR LOCAL
AND STATE ELECTION AND WILL BE
ABLE TO RETURN IT EITHER THROUGH
THE MAIL WHAT A COUNTY XCELLIS
DROP OFF LOCATION. AS CALIFORNIA
MOVES TO ENTIRELY VOTE BY MAIL
SYSTEM IT IS IMPORTANT. THAT THE
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS
TICKETS AB TAKE EVERY STEP
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THESE
BALLOTS ARE RETURNED TO THE REST
OF VOTERS. EVERY CALIFORNIA READ
DESERVES TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR STATE PROCESS AND ALSO
CONFIDENT THAT THEIR VOTE WILL
COUNT. CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
ELECTION OFFICIALS CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY A BALLOT. I
AM SEARCHING NO FIVE VOTERS AT
THE BALLOT THEY HAVE RETURNED IS
UNSIGNED OR IF THE SIGNATURES
DOES NOT MATCH. THERE'S NO SUCH
REQUIREMENT FOR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY A VOTER IF
THE BALLOT OR BALLOT ENVELOPE AS
RETURNED DAMAGED. MY BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE SAME NOTIFICATION
PROCESS FOR ANY VOTE BY MAIL
ENVELOPE THAT THE DETERMINATION
OF THE LECTION OFFICIALS IS
RECEIVED. IT DAMAGE CONDITION OR
SHOW SIGNS OF DAMAGE INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO SIGNIFICANT
RIPS TEARS OR ANY ATTEMPTS TO
UNSEAL OPEN OR BE SUED THE
OFFICIAL VOTE BY MAIL ENVELOPE.
AT NO POINT IS ANY VOTER DENIED
THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE OR ACCESS TO
THE BALLOT BOX. IF VOTERS KNOW
FIVE ABOUT ABOUT THE CONDITION
OF THEIR BALLOT ELECTION
OFFICIALS WILL PROVIDE ADVICE ON
HOW TO CORRECT THE ISSUES
INCLUDING VOTING WITH THE
PROVISIONAL BALLOT AT A POLLING
PLACE OPTING TO RECEIVE IN THE
BALLOT IN THE MAIL. THERE ARE
OPPOSITIONS TO THIS BILL. THE
LETTERS WE RECEIVED WERE BEFORE
OUR- EFFORT TO ALSO AMEND THE
BILL PER THEIR OPPOSITION THE
OPPOSITION ALL. TALKED ABOUT AT
THE MEETING OF TEMPERING OF THE
AVALON. WE HAVE TO CHANGE IT TO
USING THE DEFINITION OF A
DAMAGE. INSTEAD OF WHICH AS
MENTIONED EARLIER IS DAMAGE SHOW
SIGNS OF DAMAGE INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO SIGNIFICAN RIPS
TEARS OR ANY ATTEMPTS AND STILL
OPEN A ECENT DEFICIENT. BUT BY
MAIL ENVELOPED. I ASKED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ABSOLUTELY SAYING NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND PORT I DO
SEE WE HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION RESTORE ROSE. MISS
ROSE GOOD MORNING MORNING. RIGHT
GOOD MORNING. TO RUN MEMBERS
AMADOR ROSE DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN RESPECTFUL
BUT QUITE STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT WE HAVE HERE WE BELIEVE IS
REALLY A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT VOTER FRAUD IS
VANISHINGLY RARE AND THIS IS
TRUE EVEN IN THE STATES THAT
HAVE. LARGELY ADOPTED ALMOST ALL
VOTE BY MAIL LIKE LIKE OREGON
FOR EXAMPLE INSTEAD OF
PROTECTING THE INTEGRITY OF
ELECTIONS AB SIXTEEN SIXTY WOULD
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS THERE ARE A LOT OF
INNOCENT REASONS WHY FILE
ENVELOPES MIGHT ARRIVE IN
ELECTIONS OFFICES IN IN PERFECT
CONDITION WITH THINGS THAT ARE
CITED AS SIGNS OF DAMAGE IN THE
BILL AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE MADE BUT WE
DON'T THINK THEY FUNDAMENTALLY
ADDRESS THESE THESE ISSUES THAT
CONCERN US SO GREATLY. SO USPS
MAIL SORTERS THINK INCREASE THEY
CAN MARK THEY CAN EVEN RIP
ENVELOPES RIGHT PEOPLE MAKE
MISTAKES THEY THEY WILL OPEN
THEIR BACKUP CORRECT THE MISTAKE
SEE WHAT BACK UP WITH TAPE I'VE
DONE THAT THAT SORT OF THING
THAT WOULD CONSTITUTE DAMAGE AS
FAR AS I CAN TELL WITH THIS
BILL- WHILE THERE ARE EXAMPLES
OF WHAT DAMAGE CAUGHT. THERE'S
NO CLEAR DEATH. IN THE BILL AS
TO WHAT IS ACTUALLY DAMAGE SO.
THAT LACK OF A CLEAR DEFINITION
WE BELIEVE- CREATES A REAL
PROBLEM. SO BECAUSE OF THIS
EVERY ACCOUNT WOULD HAVE TO USE
THEIR OWN DISCRETION A RECIPE
FOR INCONSISTENT APPLICATION
THAT WOULD. TELL UNDERMINE
PUBLIC TRUST IN OUR ELECTIONS
AND THE CURA CON TOOK THE
PROCESS IT'S CONTEMPLATED BY THE
BILL WOULD NOT LEAVE TIME. FOR
MOST PEOPLE TO CAST A
REPLACEMENT BALLOT PRIOR TO THE
CLOSE OF THE ELECTION. AND THEN
THE BILL PROHIBITS ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS FROM COUNTING THE
BALLOT IF THE ENVELOPES
PERCEIVED TO BE DAMAGED SO.
HONESTLY CAN YOU IMAGINE VOTERS
REACTIONS IF THEY SIGN THEIR
BALLOT THEY TAKE THE TIME TO
FILL OUT A VERY LONG BALLOT THEY
GET EVEN IN TIME. AND THEN
EVERYTHING IS RIGHT. AND THEN
THEY GET A NOTIFICATION LATER
THAT THEIR BALLOT WASN'T COUNTED
COUNTED BECAUSE IT WAS PERCEIVED
TO BE DAMAGED. I THINK HERE
WOULD BE. IT VERY RIGHTEOUS
OUTRAGE IN THAT SIR KIND
CIRCUMSTANCE FINALLY TAMPERING
ALREADY ILLEGAL RIGHT COUNTIES
HAVE LEGAL PROCESSES IN PLACE TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT THEY PERCEIVED
TO BE TEMPERING AND GIVEN THE
RARITY OF THE PROBLEM IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE WHAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
IS SUFFICIENT. ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS REPROCESSING BALLOTS
THAT SHOW SIGNS OF VEGAN
UNDEFINED DAMAGE WOULD CAUSE
VALVO TO BE REJECTED AND IT'S A
DRACONIAN OF RESPONSE TO A
PROBLEM THAT HASN'T EVEN BEEN
SHOWN TO EXIST SO THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS MUST RESPECTFULLY
URGE A NO VOTE ON IT. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO. TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM AS
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE WE WILL NUMBER
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR CAN
OPEN UP PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR-
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TO REGISTER YOUR POSITION ON
SIXTEEN SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A FEW
QUEUING UP FOR THE FIRST TWO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT WILL
HAVE FOR THIS. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS WITH DOCTOR COUNTY ANNEX
STRONGLY OPPOSE YEAH. REX'S LINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOR A MOMENT ONE FIFTY THREE IT
MIGHT HANG UP IS A LITTLE BIT
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY LIKE
CRITICAL WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW GO
AHEAD PLEASE. RIGHT THANK YOU
HELLO KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER MURRAY BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PAPER FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. TEXAS LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY THREE CAN YOU GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MY NAME'S PERRY
LEVINE AYE VOTE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY FOUR AND I OPPOSE
AB. SIXTEEN SIXTY. LINE FIFTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. WHAT THE
ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. UNLINED
FIFTY ONE GO AND FIX. YEAH THIS
IS MERRY BEST FIELDER AND EIGHTY
FIFTY FOUR AND I'M OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU HAVE A
FAVORITE WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
WERE IN THE PUBLIC IF YOU. ONE
FIFTY NINE IT'S GOING TO. I.
YEAH THE NIGHT WE CAN YOU GO
AHEAD PLEASE SORRY MY NAME IS
KERRY CORGAN'S CHILDREN THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
SEVENTY NINE. I SUPPORT A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS IS WE ARE
ON A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY. BUT
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA WANDER I AM A
CONSTITUENTS IN HANNAH
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO PRESS ONE ZERO TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR SIXTEEN SIXTEEN DON KNAPP
TWO ONE NUMBER NINE FIVE PLEASE
. HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOUR- YES-
THIS IS STEPHANIE SEVILLA I'M IN
DISTRICTS THAT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT. THANK YOU. THANKS
TO THE LINE NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT THINGS GOING ON. I SIR
ROOSEVELT IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR
THE NEW ID FIFTY FIVE THIS IS
ABSURD STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
. SIX POINT FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHETHER KELLER SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THE
LION FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THIRTY NINE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD
PLEASE ALL GREAT HI MY NAME IS
SURE TO WATCH I'M CALLING FROM
DR COUNTY THEY REPRESENT JAMES
BRADLEY FOR U. S. SENATE. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL. THANK
YOU WITH THAT MISTER CHEROKEE
WAS QUICK. THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
WILL NOW TURN TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WITH QUESTIONS COMMENTS FOR THE
OFFICE. SEEING NINETY MAKE
CLOTHES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN. AS MENTIONED AT NO POINT
IN THIS BILL THAT THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER ARE BEING DENIED THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE OR ACCESS TO THE
BALLOT BOX. IF THE VOTERS NOTIFY
ABOUT THE CONDITION OF THEIR
BALLOTS ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
WOULD PROVIDE ADVICE ON HOW TO
CORRECT THE ISSUE INCLUDING
BOATING WITH ONE IN. THE BALLOT
AT A POLLING PLACE. FOR TO OPT
IN TO RECEIVING THE BALLOT IN
THE MAIL. AS MENTIONED THE WORD
TAMPERING WAS THE MAIN CONCERNS
OF THE ALL THE OPPOSITIONS WE
REMOVE THE WORD AND WE NOW HAVE
USED DEVOID DAMAGE. I WISH I BET
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN'S VOTERS. IN
MAKING THIS AN ISSUE THAT IS NOT
IT IS ABOUT A DAMAGE ENVELOPE
THAT IF YOU. THE BACHELOR VOTERS
SEES IT. IF AGAIN IF IT HAS
SIGNIFICANT RIPS TEARS OR ANY
ATTEMPTS TO UNSEAL OPENER
RECEIVED OFFICIAL VOTE BY MAIL
HELLO THE VOTER IS NOTIFIED. THE
VOTER CAN EASILY TELL THE REST
OF VOTERS ONCE THEY NOTIFY. THAT
WAS ME GO AHEAD PROCESS MY
BALANCE. NOT SAYING THE
REGISTERED VOTERS CAN STILL NOT
CALL AND IF THEY WERE CALLED AND
THEY CAN JUST THROW AWAY THE
BALLOT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BILL
IS. SO I WISH THAT YOU KNOW HAVE
BEEN REACH OUT AGAIN- AFTER
WE'VE MADE EVERY ATTEMPT. TO
MAKE THIS BILL S. IT IS VERY
SIMPLE. OF AND SO. AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I FELT. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
QUORUM IS NOT PRESENT SO WE WILL
VOTE ON IT SHORTLY I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL I
THINK IT MIGHT BE A SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM AS WAS
MENTIONED THERE ARE MANY WAYS-
THAT A VOTE BY MAIL ENVELOPE
COULD BE ACCIDENTALLY DAMAGED.
AND VOTERS LEGITIMATELY MAKE
MISTAKES AND THEY TRY TO CORRECT
THEM AND IN THOSE INSTANCES
THOSE VOTES WON'T BE COUNTED-
QUICK ENOUGH BEFORE THE ELECTION
CLOSES I ANSWER THOSE FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY BUT WE WILL HAVE
A FULL COMMITTEE VOTE ASSUMING
IT GETS A MOTION NOW WHEN WE
HAVE A CORE. YES MAY I RESPOND
TO THAT MISTER. I THINK I GET
THE LAST WORD RESPECTFULLY.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE.
I THINK THAT STAY HERE YES. OKAY
THE FOURTEENTH WITH YOUR REGULAR
NUMBER YEAH. YOUR OTHER
WITNESSES IS ON THE PHONE C. AS
A MEMBER WE'RE GONNA AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL ESTABLISHED FORMER
. WHAT WE DO THAT. BROWN BRIAN
HERE SAY ARE TELL BANDIT. HERE
BENNETT HERE LOW LOW HERE MAYES
PLEASE LEAVE HERE BLANCA RUBIO.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY REAFFIRMS A FOUNDING
PRINCIPLE OF THIS NATION AND
PROTECTS THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOCRATIC SELF GOVERNMENT FROM
FOREIGN PRINCIPLES AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. I WOULD LIMIT THE
INFLUENCE OF FOREIGN COUNTRIES
AND ENTITIES WHO OWN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SHARES IN
THE US SPACE CORPORATION FROM
BEING ABLE TO EXERT INFLUENCE
OVER OUR ELECTIONS. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL. A CORPORATION WILL BE
DEEMED A FOREIGN INFLUENCE IF A
FOREIGN ENTITY PARTICIPATE IN
DECISION MAKING WITH RESPECT TO
STATE OR LOCAL PARK POLITICAL
SPENDING OR- OR 1% OF SHARES ARE
OWNED BY A SINGLE. FOREIGN
INVESTOR 5% ARE OWNED BY
MULTIPLE FOR INVESTORS SHORTLY
AFTER THE TWENTY TEN CITIZENS
UNITED RULING THEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA WARNED IN THE STATE OF THE
UNION. THAT THE SUPREME COURT
HAD OPENED THE DOOR TO FOREIGN
MONEY IN U. S. ELECTIONS DURING
THAT SPEECH JUSTICE ALITO'S
INFAMOUSLY TOOK HIS HEAD AND
MOUTH NOT TRUE HOWEVER. TWELVE
YEARS LATER WE HAVE EVIDENCE
THAT THIS HOLDS TRUE AS
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA WARNED
FOREIGN INVESTMENTS IN U. S.
COMPANIES HAVE SKYROCKETED
RECENTLY. YEARS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO FOREIGN INVESTORS OWN
ONLY ABOUT 5% OF ALL US
CORPORATE EQUITY BY NICK TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT NUMBER JUMPED TO
FORTY PERCENT. WHILE FOREIGN
INVESTORS ARE PROHIBITED BY
FEDERAL LAW FROM SPENDING MONEY
TO INFLUENCE U. S. ELECTIONS
THERE IS A BIG LOOPHOLE BEING
EXPLOITED BY FOREIGN INVESTORS
WITH LARGE AMOUNTS OF CAPITAL
AND US SHARES OF CORPORATIONS.
OWNING OF SHARES. YOUR
CORPORATION CAN AMOUNT TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITH. DIRECT LINES TO CEO AND
BEING ABLE TO MAKE STOCKHOLDER
MOTIONS. THIS POLICY REFORM IS
NEEDED AND BEING DISCUSSED IN
CONGRESS AT THROUGHOUT OTHER
STATES LEGISLATURES INCLUDING
NEW YORK MASSACHUSETTS MINNESOTA
HAWAII AND OREGON MOST RECENTLY
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE THE TENTH
LARGEST CITY IN THE COUNTRY. AND
MY HOME CITY VOTED TO MOVE
FORWARD TO DRAFTING A SIMILAR
FORM TO AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AN
EFFORT TO LIMIT FOR INFANTS
CORPORATE SPENDING. AND ALSO OF
COURSE INFAMOUS ARE FAMOUSLY THE
CITY OF SEATTLE HAS PASSED THEIR
ONE SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN. AS WE
LOOK AROUND THE WORLD SAUDI
ARABIA HAS ANNOUNCED EARLY THIS
YEAR THEY PLAN TO INVEST TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE COMPANY'S
MORE THAN DOUBLING ITS ASSETS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS SUCH AS WHEN AND-
BLAVATNIK HAVE A TIED TO HAVE
BEEN TIED TO MILLIONS. OF
DOLLARS IN CONTRIBUTIONS
INFORMED TO INFLUENCE ELECTIONS
AND A SOVEREIGN WEALTH FUND OF
NORWAY HAS A STAKE IN AROUND ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED COMPANIES
WITHIN AVERAGE HOLDING OF ONE
POINT 4% OF ALL CHAIRS. ACROSS
THE COUNTRY MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS AND FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS HAVE USED THEIR
MONEY AND POWER TO INFLUENCE THE
OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS ADVANCE
ENGINES IN THEIR FAVOR. IT IS
TIME WE PUT AN END TO FOREIGN
ACTORS USING THEIR POWER AND
WEALTH TO INFLUENCE CALIFORNIA'S
MARCUS IT IS THE PULSE. I WOULD
THAT I COULD USE MY TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITH ME
I'VE DOOR ROSE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS AND THE PHONE. WILL HAVE
COURTNEY HOSTETLER SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR FEES FREE SPEECH FOR
PEOPLE ARE CALLING IN FROM
WASHINGTON DC. THANK YOU MISTER
LEE MISS ROSE LONG TIME NO SEE.
C. DOOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR LEGAL
CAL HERE IN SOME OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. SO THE LYNC BELIEVES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ELECTIONS AND
OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM OVERALL
REALLY. SHOULD PRIORITIZE VOTERS
RIGHT NOT BIG MONEY NOT SPECIAL
INTERESTS AND OUR CAMPAIGN
FINANCE SYSTEM SHOULD MAXIMIZE
PEOPLE'S PARTICIPATION IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS IT SHOULD
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY ABOUT WHERE
THE MONEY'S COMING FROM WHICH TO
COMBAT CORRUPTION. IT SHOULD
ALSO WORK TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR- FOR EQUITABLE
COMPETITION IN ELECTIONS
CITIZENS UNITED AS AS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAH INDICATED
HAS HAS CREATED THIS LOOPHOLE
RIGHT ONE THAT ALLOWS FOREIGN
INVESTORS TO CIRCUMVENT LAWS
AGAINST POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS
THROUGH SECURING CORPORATE.
OWNERSHIP INTERESTS A LOOPHOLE
THAT HAS ENJOYED DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED- USE RECENT YEARS WITH
RAPIDLY EXPANDING FOREIGN
INVESTMENT IN US COMPANIES
FOREIGN INFLUENCED CORPORATIONS
HAVE BY DO SHERRY
RESPONSIBILITIES RIGHT THEY ARE
ANSWERABLE TO THEIR SHAREHOLDERS
SAY DO NOT CENTER THE INTERESTS
OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS THE WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS. ARE
ELECTIONS HAVE GOT TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE INTERESTS OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND NOT
SKEWED TOWARD FOREIGN INTERESTS.
IT WE ARE EXPERIENCING A REAL
CRISIS OF DEMOCRACY. AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AND IT'S FED BY
MISSING DISINFORMATION THAT HAS
BEEN PERPETRATED TO A VERY
DISTURBING DEGREE BY CERTAIN
FOREIGN POWERS. MONEY IN
POLITICS AS A CORRUPTING
INFLUENCE IN ALMOST ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CORRECTIONS
REALLY MAGNIFIED WHEN CITIZENS
OF OTHER COUNTRIES ARE ALLOWED
TO INFLUENCE ELECTIONS BY
INVESTING IN US COMPANIES. AB
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN PROHIBITS
CORPORATIONS WITH CERTAIN
PERCENTAGES OF FOREIGN PRINCIPAL
OWNERSHIP OR YOU KNOW WERE
FOREIGN ENTITIES PARTICIPATE IN
POLITICAL SPENDING DECISIONS FOR
MAKING CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
AND EXPENDITURES SO THE LOSURE
OF THE CITIZENS UNITED LOOPHOLES
GOING TO HELP AVOID POLITICAL
MANIPULATION BY FOREIGN
INFLUENCED CORPORATIONS IT'LL
PRESERVE PUBLIC TRUST. IN OUR
ELECTIONS IN OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND IT'S ALSO GOING TO
PREVENT WHAT IS IT YOU KNOW
IT'LL PROTECT THE REPRESENTATIVE
NATURE OF OUR DEMOCRACY THAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT IT'S GONNA DO
SO THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS.
FIVE VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS ROSE WHEN I MOVE ON TO
MISS. HOSTETLER. MORNING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. HI DEAR ME YES
WE CAN. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS FROM
FOREIGN INFLUENCE. CURRENTLY
FEDERAL IN CALIFORNIA ALLOWED
YOU TO PROHIBIT FOREIGN ENTITIES
FROM SPENDING ANY MONEY ZERO
DOLLARS INFLUENCE U. S.
ELECTIONS EITHER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY. BUT CURRENTLY THE
SAME ENTITIES WHICH INCLUDE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS CORPORATIONS
AND WEALTHY FOREIGN PRINTABLES
FOR LOCATED OUTSIDE THE UNIT
EIGHT. CAN STILL INFLUENCE
ELECTION BY INVESTING IN THE US
COMPANIES THAT CAN THEN.
UNLIMITED DOLLARS ON A LOT OF
TRIMMING NORMA CORPORATE
TREASURY. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MENTIONED AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN INCLUDES THE FOOTBALL
IT WOULD PROHIBIT FOR PROFIT
FOREIGN INFLUENCE BUSINESS
ENTITIES FROM SPENDING MONEY ON
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS. EITHER
COMPANIES IN WHICH SHE SINGLE
FOREIGN STAKEHOLDER OWNS AT
LEAST 1% OF THE COMPANY OR ITS
SHARES OR IN WHICH MORE THAN ONE
STATE FOREIGN STAKEHOLDER OWNS
AN AGGREGATE FIVE PERCENT.
OBERNOLTE S. B. C. AND OTHER
CORPORATE EXPERTS LOOK AT 1%
OWNERSHIP AS ACTUALLY AN UPPER
LIMIT BENCHMARK AT WHICH AN
OWNER CAN INFLUENCE A LARGE
CORPORATION. SHE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN INCOME. BECAUSE OUR
COURTS TREAT ELECTION
CONTRIBUTION DIFFERENTLY BASED
ON WHERE THE MONEY COMES FROM IS
IT BEING SPENT BY US CITIZEN OR
PERMANENT RESIDENT OR THE BEING
SPENT BY A FOREIGN ENTITY. IN
CITIZENS UNITED THE SUPREME
COURT DETERMINED THAT CORPORATE
ELECTION SPENDING IS PROTECTED
SPEECH BECAUSE U. S.
CORPORATIONS ARE INCLUDING HERE
ASSOCIATIONS OF CITIZENS. JUST
TWO YEARS LATER THE SUPREME
COURT JENNIFER NEED A DIFFERENT
LOWER COURT DECISION. THE FCC
WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY NOW
JUSTICE CABIN ON- THAT HELD THE
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITING ANY
SPENDING ON ELECTION BY FOREIGN
ENTITIES BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT
HAS A VESTED INTEREST IN
PROTECTING OUR DEMOCRATIC SELF
GOVERNANCE IMPORTANT. THAT THE
MONEY IF YOU THERE WAS SOMETHING
LIKE FIFTY DOLLARS BUT A FOREIGN
EXCHANGE STUDENT CENTER THE KING
GOES OUT TO PRINT FIRED IN
SUPPORT OF A CANDIDATE SOMETHING
FAR BELOW THE ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF MONEY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- PROHIBITING WITH. FOREIGN
INFLUENCE BUSINESS ENTITIES HERE
. COOPER HAS. UNUSUALLY THE BY
AND CAN INCOME BY. A FOREIGN
ENTITY IT'S NO LONGER AN
ASSOCIATION SAID. FOUR
INVESTMENT CAN BE A USEFUL TOOL
FOR CORPORATE GROW GROW. BUT IT
SHOULDN'T BE A WAY IN WHICH
FOREIGN RESOURCES AND INFLUENCE
CAN AND ARE ELECTIONS THEREFORE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO. MOVE THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I'VE BEEN GOVERNMENT I SEE YOU
HERE TODAY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- PENDULUM
BACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- I WANT
TO JUST ADDRESS A RIGHT AT THE
TOP THE QUESTION I'VE GOTTEN THE
MOST ABOUT THIS BILL WHICH IS
HOW MANY BUSINESSES WOULD HAVE
PROHIBITED FROM CONTRIBUTING TO
CAMPAIGNS- HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MORE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
DO A FULL ASSESSMENT ON A MORE
THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND PLUS
MEMBERS OR THE MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND BUSINESSES
REGISTERED TO OPERATE IN THE
STATE- I WOULD POINT OUT TO THE
BILL'S SPONSORS ON STUDY. WHICH
SHOWS THAT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
PERMIT 98% OF S. AND P. FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS THAT'S 98% CHAU. THE
BILL ALSO RAISES CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTIONS I KNOW. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- AND SPONSORS HAVE
REFERRED TO A SIMILAR PROPOSAL
IN SEATTLE- HOWEVER AT THE
WASHINGTON STATE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY'S REQUEST- PERKINS CARILLO
LONGTIME MOSTLY DEMOCRATIC LAW
FIRM. DID AN ANALYSIS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND- THEY RESPONDED BY
SAYING THAT QUOTE IT WOULD
ALMOST CERTAINLY FACE
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGE IN SUCH
A CHALLENGE WOULD HAVE A STRONG
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS ON THE
MERITS. OF THE COMMITTEE HEARS
VERY. SMART ANALYSIS POINTS THAT
QUOTE IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THIS
BILL COULD RESTRICT THE ABILITY
OF BUSINESS ENTITIES TO MAKE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND EXPENDITURES
IN ELECTIONS BASED ON RELATIVELY
LOW LEVELS OF FOREIGN OWNERSHIP.
IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER A COURT
WOULD UPHOLD THIS BILL AGAINST A
CHALLENGE THAT ITS PROVISIONS
VIOLATE THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION- WE ALSO
FIND THE BILL. A FAIRLY BROAD-
AND- WHILE IT WOULD LIKELY APPLY
TO- CONCORD AMERICAN BUSINESSES-
A PARAPHRASE ONE SECTION FROM
THE ANALYSIS HERE WHICH REALLY
DIDN'T EXCELLENT JOB THAT- EVEN
WERE A BUSINESS THAT IS
ORGANIZED UNDER THE LAWS OF THE
U. S. HAS ITS PRINCIPAL PLACE OF
BUSINESS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE'RE ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THE- PROCESS. THE
BILL MAKES POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THIS BUSINESS
COULD STILL BE PROHIBITED BY
THIS BILL FOR MAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS OR EXPENDITURES.
IN STATE AND LOCAL ELECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA- IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS MEANT TO HAVE THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY UNILATERALLY
DISARM IN TERMS OF ITS
PARTICIPATION IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS- WE FIND SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS ALSO SOME OF
PUNITIVE AND DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT INCLUDING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT IF THE BUSINESS
MAKES A CONTRIBUTION. THE CEO
HIMSELF OR HERSELF HAS TO SIGN A
STATEMENT OF CERTIFICATION THE
PROMISES THAT THE BUSINESS IS
NOT HAVE FOREIGN INVESTORS
WITHIN SEVEN DAYS OF MAKING THAT
CONTRIBUTION. AND THE FINAL SHOW
REYES- IS WHAT I CALL THE PASS
THROUGH PROVISION- AND I HAD TO
READ THIS A FEW TIMES TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTOOD IT BUT
ESSENTIALLY- THE BILL PROHIBITS
A PERSON WHO RECEIVED A
CONTRIBUTION- FROM THEN USING
THAT CONTRIBUTION TO MAKE A
SUBSEQUENT CONTRIBUTION- TO A
CANDIDATE BALLOT MEASURE XCERRA-
OR TO CONTRIBUTE TO ANOTHER
PERSON FOR THE PURPOSES OF
MAKING A CONTRIBUTION- UNLESS
THEY- ALSO RECEIVED FROM THE
BILL. A COPY OF THE STATEMENT A
CERTIFICATION THAT THE BUSINESS
ENTITY IS NOT A FOREIGN
INFLUENCE BUSINESS I HAVE TO BE
HONEST WHEN I READ THE BILL I
ASSUME THAT IT WAS BEING
SPONSORED BY AN ASSOCIATION OF
CAMPAIGN LAWYER SOME TREASURES
BECAUSE THIS WOULD CREATE AN
EXPLOSION IN TERMS OF THE JOBS
THAT THESE INDUSTRIES- IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES TO COMPLY WITH THIS-
BUT IN SHORT. ONE LEGISLATOR
RECEIVED A CONTRIBUTION FROM ONE
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES YOU WOULD
ALSO HAVE TO GO- TO THE HOT
ORIGINAL BUSINESS THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO YOUR COLLEAGUE
AND ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
STATEMENT OF CERTIFICATION- ROM
THE CEO. OF FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE OPPOSED TO AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO. A
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM WERE
THERE ANY WITNESSES. HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. MY NAME IS SHANE
MCLEOD AND FROM SACRAMENTO AND
I'M REPRESENTING MONEY OUT
VOTERS IN AND WE ARE AMONG THE
PRIMARY SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK. I AM
SOMETHING THAT'S SIMPLY A
SHALLOW WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SINGH NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM WE'RE NOW GONNA MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES. IN THE QUEUE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN NINETEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE A FEW KEEPING UP.
WILL GO FIRST TO LINE THE NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO IS GOING
TO. HI MARK NO I'M WITH A
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
THE NEXUS LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY ONE THREE ONE
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE
- MY NAME IS AL WEIGH IN ON
PRESIDENT OF L. A. X. AREA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ENERGY TO PASS IT OUT
TO THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
THANKS IS LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWENTY THREE
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE. IT MOVING ON THE LINE SIXTY
THREE LINE SIXTY THREE SO HE'S
GOING TO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
KRISTINA LYNCH A RESIDENT AT
SAUNDERS HOUSE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE EIGHT TWENTY
NINE AND URGE YOU TO PASS IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE. THANK YOU NEXUS
LINE THIRTY TWO THREE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES JENNIFER HANNER ON
BEHALF OF ALL EIGHTY THREE
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG. STRONG SUPPORT APRIL.
EIGHTEEN NINETY. NEXT IN LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WITH THE ROMERO CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE CONTACT. HI THIS IS HOLLY MOSER WITH
MONEY OUT VOTERS IN SANTA MONICA
US CODE IS CLEAR THE PROBLEMS
FOR AN MONEY IN U. S. ELECTIONS.
THE COURT NAME ORGANIZATION
ACTION ON THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. REMINDER FOR ALL OTHER
CALLERS NINE ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL WE GOT
PRETTY HEALTHY CAL. LUNCH
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVENTY TWO WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD PLEASE YES- IN STAPLETON
OF THE PUBLIC POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR THE HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
AND ALSO AN ELECTED MEMBER OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BOTH IS VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
EMERGING MARKETS EMERGING ABOUT
SOMEBODY SOMEBODY TO. THE THING
THAT I'M. OPERATOR NEXT LINE
PLEASE. THAT'S WHY MY TWENTY
GOING TO WATCHING. YEP WHAT WE
THE AUDIO ON OTHER SIDE OF THAT
LINE. TO TWO TWENTY SEVEN ONE
ONE ONE ONE. YES DJ OPERATOR.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME FEEDBACK ON
THE WEB SITE OF SOME OF YOUR-
WILL TRY AGAIN ONE TWENTY TO
WILL BE LIKE DOUBLE CD FOR
SIGNIFICANT ROOSTER. OKAY
OPERATORS A SOMETHING YOU WE CAN
FIX OR DO WE NEED TO MOVE ON-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON HERE JUST
A MOMENT TO TROUBLESHOOTING
MODEL HERE- THAT IS. THE
FEEDBACK THAT'S COMING IN- WEBEX
CONNECTION SUPPORT- WILL TRY THE
NEXT LINES. THERE ON THE LINE.
FIFTY ONE ONE FIFTY ONE BILL AT
THIS. YES THIS IS MEREDITH FEEL
THERE- FROM EIGHTY FOUR LOS
ANGELES OFF MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU WELL LINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE. HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU HELLO HELLO. YES MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA WANDER I AM A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE TRONG
INDIVISIBLE INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE HELLO I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. BLIND SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS FELIX I LIVE IN MILPITAS
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN FROM THE
PORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THE
LINE FORTY EIGHT POINT SINCE.
GREETING FAILING FELLER AT SIXTY
TWO AND CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC ONE PARTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISSPELLING.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN WHICH IS GOING
TO. MY NAME IS KELLY HALL A
PRIVATE CITIZEN FROM DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN DROPPED A Q.
ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN
WITH YOU GUYS THIS. OKAY CORKER
OF INDIVISIBLE VENTURA AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ONE SIXTY PLEASE GOING TO
. MY NAME IS TO REMAIN ON THE
DAILY FILE ME MEMBER OF BERKELEY
DEMOCRATIC CLUB BUT I'M CALLING
AT THE PRIVATE CITIZEN TICKET IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
DESPITE THIS OUT OF COMMITTEE
THANKYOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. LINE TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ONE TWENTY WORKING HERE
YOU PLEASE BUT- THANK. THE HELP
I'M THANKS FOR THE HELP. MIXES
LINE NUMBER EIGHT ONE NUMBER
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
SERVER I AM VOTE IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FORM ELECTED MEMBER OF L.
A. C. P. AND V. P. AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. ONE THIRTY THREE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS
REBECCA DEAN AND I AM BUT
INDIVISIBLE EAST BAY CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. MIX OF ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE WHAT. WHAT
PARTS ARE COUNTING ON STRONG
OPPOSITIONL. THE LION THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY WE
CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE
YOU'RE SORRY I COULDN'T HEAR YOU
I DEBRA EL GHARBIA SCANNERS DAY
AND STOCKPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THE LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS A RUSH DAY I'M WITH
CHANGE BEGINS WITH ME ANYWHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT TO THE FLOOR AND KICKED IT TO
OUR ATTENTION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THIRTY EIGHT WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACK BOROFF IN
STUDIO CITY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL URGING YOU
TO PASS A FORWARD PLEASE. MIXES
LINES ONE. ON IN. FIVE EIGHT Y.
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINES OPEN WANNA
PACIFIC.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO IN CLEAR IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. TWENTY FORTY FOUR.
HI HEATHER TAYLOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
. I MLI AT SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MICHELLE FEATHER
DIRECTOR OF MOVING MONEY OUT
SENATORS AND WHERE THE
CALIFORNIA SPONSORS OF AB
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND WE WOULD
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ADVANCE
THE BILL THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
Q. IS QUICKER. THANK YOU MISTER
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW TURN TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WITH QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS FOR THE AUTHOR. SEEING NONE MISTER LEE YOU MAY
NOW CLOSE. WELL I WOULD FOR THE
FIRST THANK THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
LETTING US HAVE A GREAT PROVIDES
HEARING TODAY ABOUT IT I JUST
WANNA DRESS SOME OF THE POINTS
BROUGHT UP IN OUR CONVERSATION
TODAY AND ALSO THANKED THE
OPPOSITION COMING FORWARD WITH
THOSE ATTRACTIVE FIT AB FEEDBACK
IN PRISM BUT I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THE
SEATTLE CASES THAT SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE HAS BEEN NO
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGER HAS
BEEN A COURT CHALLENGE. AND WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT SEATTLE IS
HOME TO AMAZON THE LARGEST
CORPORATION BASED IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THEY HAVE NOT DONE IT
AND THAT IS BECAUSE AS OUR- THIS
IS TESTIFIED. IT WOULD PULLED UP
AND GOT SCORE. HOWEVER WE NEVER
HAD THE TESTS TO DO SO. BUT I
DON'T THINK IT ACTUALLY WOULD BE
FOUND UNCONSTITUTIONAL IF GIVEN
THAT THAT'S THE REALITY. HAVING
GONE THROUGH TWO ELECTION CYCLES
NOW. WELL THEY HAVE NOT HAD IT
BEEN CHALLENGE AT ALL. AND ALSO
WHAT WHY THIS BILL SO IMPORTANT
TO AND SOMETHING TO STRESS ABOUT
HIS. YEAH THIS IS DIRECT MONEY
FROM THEIR SEATS FROM THE FOR
INVESTORS GOING TO CORPORATE
TREASURIES. THEN GOING INTO OUR
ELECTIONS. THAT IS A HUGE
CIRCUMVENTION. OF FEDERAL LAW.
GLARING LOOPHOLE IN CITIZENS
UNITED. ESSES UNITED HAD
STRESSED THAT CORPORATIONS COULD
SPEND BECAUSE UNLIMITED
SPENDING. BECAUSE THEY WERE
ASSOCIATIONS OF CITIZENS WELL
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE
ASSOCIATION HAS A SIGNIFICANT. A
CONTROLLING INTEREST OR
SIGNIFICANT SHAREHOLDER WHO IS
NOT A CITIZEN. AND THAT IS THE
CASE. HERE ONE OF. THE TOP
TWENTY ONE TO WELL ALL SORTS
IMMIGRANTS AND FOR CAPITAL BUT
WE MUST MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR ELECTIONS WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS. A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND TO CLOSE ON A QUOTE FORMER
CEO OF US SPACE EXXON MOBIL IN
THIS IN THIS INFAMOUS QUOTE. I'M
NOT A US COMPANY I DON'T MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON WHAT'S GOOD
FOR THE US IT'S TIME TO REIN IN
FOREIGN INFLUENCE. AND PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR SELF
GOVERNANCE SO I WOULD LIKE TO.
RESPECT NATURE I BET. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT WASN'T HERE FOR
THE- MOMENT I. JUST HAVE A VERY
QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU MADE A
COMMENT AND I DIDN'T QUITE CATCH
IT YOU SAID THAT- FOREIGN
OWNERSHIP WENT FROM 9% TO EITHER
40% OR 14% AND I DIDN'T HEAR.
740% FIVE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO. 221940% FOUR ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BASICALLY WE'VE HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF PASSION
SUPPORTERS TODAY. ON THIS BILL I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO TOOK
THEIR TIME TO TESTIFY. I THINK
THE OPPOSITION HAS MADE SOME
POINTS THAT ARE WORTH
CONSIDERING. I WAS CONTINUING TO
WORK THROUGH- THERE IS A LOT TO
UNPACK IN THIS BILL I KNOW
SOMEWHERE EFFORT WAS TRIED. A
LAST YEAR AND I SEE THAT THOSE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN LARGELY
ADDRESSED- IN A MORE THOUGHTFUL
WAY THIS YEAR. AND WITH THAT I
AM RECOMMENDING. THIS COMMITTEE
MOVE THIS BILL ON TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND SO
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY CAN WE
CALL THE ROLL. I'LL IS THERE A
MOTION. MISTER BENNETT SECOND I
MISSED LOW. BUT NO ONE CALLED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN BRIAN I
SEYARTO BENNETT BENNETT I LOW
WELL I MAYES LEE HI LEE I BLANCA
RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO IS NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU LOSE OUT. MR
LEVINE. IT HAPPENED BELATED GOOD
SIR YOU. THIS IF YOU WANT AS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
IS A GREAT PERSON YESTERDAY AND
I WAS PLEASED TO CELEBRATE IT
WITH YOU GUYS DURING THE DAY AND
WITH MY FAMILY LAST NIGHT- IF I
MAY AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
EXPENSE DISCLOSURE SO ESSENTIAL
TO ENSURING GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY BY APPLYING
EXISTING LOBBYIST REGISTRATION
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TWO
INDIVIDUALS ARE LOBBYING FIRM
SEEKING TO INFLUENCE INSURANCE
MERGER DECISIONS THIS BILL
REMEDIES AN ONGOING PROBLEM
RECENTLY REPORTED IN THE
SACRAMENTO BEE WORK CONSULTANTS
WERE TO BE PAID A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR CONTINGENCY FEE TO
INFLUENCE THE APPROVAL OF AN
INSURANCE COMPANY ACQUISITION.
WHILE THE V. EIGHTEEN PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE LAWS FOR LOBBYING
ACTIVITY BECAUSE INSURANCE IS
SUCH AN ESSENTIAL PRODUCT
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE UNIQUELY
IMPORTANT TO CONSUMERS CHANGES
IN CONTROL OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES CAN HAVE DRAMATIC
IMPLICATIONS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS UNDERSCORING THE
DRAMATIC IMPACT THAT SUCH
MERGERS CAN HAVE ON CONSUMERS AS
WELL AS THE IMPORTANCE OF AN
UNBIASED DETERMINATION OF THE
MERITS OF SUCH ACTIONS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A BILL WAS ENACTED TO
REQUIRE PRIOR APPROVAL OF
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS BY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE TO MAYOR
REQUIREMENTS ALREADY IN PLACE
FOR MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS OF
COMPANIES REGULATED. BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WOULD
SIMPLY MAKE EFFORTS TO INFLUENCE
THOSE DECISIONS SUBJECT TO
EXISTING LOBBYING REQUIREMENTS
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
LANDMARK LAW HELPS DELIVER
GREATER GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY
BY INSTITUTINGCERTAIN REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE AND
REGULATIONS ON WHAT LOBBYISTS DO
. WHILE OTHER POLITICAL REFORM
ACT HAS TIGHT REGULATIONS
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS AND
LOBBYING RESTRICTIONS MANY OF
THESE RESTRICTIONS ONLY APPLY TO
LOBBYING ON LEGISLATIVE ACTIVITY
DID NOT CAPTURE BROAD SWATHS OF
ACTIVITY THAT LOBBYISTS AND-
CONSULTANTS MAY ENGAGE. IN TO
INFLUENCE POLICY IN WAYS THAT
WILL AFFECT THEIR CLIENTS AND
CALIFORNIANS IN SIGNIFICANT
WAYS. AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
WILL CLOSE A DISTURBING LOOPHOLE
IN OUR POLITICAL PRACTICES LAWS
THAT ALLOW A PERSON TO
CIRCUMVENT. LOBBYING RULES AND
PROHIBITIONS WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS JERRY FLANAGAN
CHIEF TRIAL COUNSEL FOR CONSUMER
WATCHDOG IS FLANAGAN TO SEE
THANK YOU AT GERMAN BRIAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE COULD SEE
ALL. THE PUBLIC REFORM ACT AS
YOU KNOW WAS ADOPTED IN THE WAKE
OF WATERGATE TO RESTORE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE BY REQUIRING PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE. OF LOBBYING ACTIVITY
IN MAKING SURE THAT THE PUBLIC
BUSINESSES CONTEST CONDUCTED.
FOR ALL TO SEE CIRCLING A B.
ARTICLE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE- HAVE WRECKED THE
REFERENCE PERFECTLY CAPTURES THE
ISSUE OF SO CALLED CONSULTANTS
WHO ARE LOBBYIST FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. INFLUENCING
ADMINISTRATIVE DECISIONS. WHILE
AVOIDING THE PUBLIC REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT THERE ARE TWO FORMER
LAWMAKERS WERE HIRED BY WORKERS
COMP INSURER TO INFLUENCE THE
DECISION OF THE INSURANCE COME.
OUT REGARDING IT IN A MERGER AT
STAKE WERE POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN- OVER
CHARGES FOR BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS THE CONSULTANTS WERE
TO BE PAID A TWO MILLION DOLLAR
CONTINGENCY FEE CONTRACT FOR
THAT LOBBYING ACTIVITY. AND THIS
IS A COMPANY BY CLOAKED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CONCEAL THEIR
TRUE SOURCE THESE EFFORTS TO
INFLUENCE HAVE ALL THE HALLMARKS
OF LOBBYING. AND CONSUMERS
DESERVE THE TRUTH PARENTS AB
SEVENTY EIGHTY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE AB SEVENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
PART ME DOES NOT TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL IT DOES NOT CREATE ANY NEW
SUBSTANTIVE REQUIREMENTS BUT
MERELY APPLIES EXISTING DISK.
IT'S AB SEVENTY EIGHT THE
MEASURE APPROACH. STATE LAW ALL
DEFINE A LOT- AS ANYONE BEING
PAID TO INFLUENCE A DECISION
REGARDING ADMINISTRATIVE
DECISION. HOWEVER THAT AS THE
COMEDIAN ALICE NOTES. A NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ADVICE OPINIONS
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT- NARROWLY INTERPRETED
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS TO
EXCLUDE EFFORTS TO INFLUENCE
AGENCIES DECISIONS- AND THAT'S
BEEN INTERPRETED OPPOSED THAT
DECISION TO APPLY TO MERGERS
ACQUISITIONS. A LOT CAN BE SAID
ABOUT THAT BUT NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WAS A LONG TIME AGO THINGS
HAVE CHANGED. AB SNOT SANTINI
THREE IMPORTANT ALSO FALLS THIS
COMMITTEES PRIOR INCREMENTAL AND
TARGETED CHANGE TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
TEN THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS
COMMITTEE AMENDED THE DEFINITION
OF AN ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION
WHICH IS HAPPENING HERE- TO
INCLUDE LOBBYING. EFFORTS TO
INFLUENCE DECISIONS BY CALPERS
WHEN INVESTING RETIREMENT FUNDS
FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OBVIOUSLY
DOES REPORT DECISIONS AS WELL. I
WANT TO GO TO THE COMEDIAN. I
REALLY FOCUSES ON THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN PAS I
LEGISLATIVE AND CLAWS IDEATIONAL
DECISIONS WAS A LOT TO BE SAID
ABOUT THAT ANYONE HAVE
QUESTIONS. BUT ONCE YOU GET PAST
ALL THOSE TECHNICAL TERMS REALLY
THE ISSUE HERE IS THE TYPE OF
ACTIVITY. THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
HERE IS PRECISELY LOBBYING AND
IT'S PRECISELY THE TYPE OF
ACTIVITY THAT THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT WANTED APPLIED PUBLIC
DISCLOSURES TO. ALSO THE
POLITICALREFORM ACTINIUM TO
FIND QUALIFIED LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDING THAT DEFINITION. WAS
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY TEN IN ORDER TO EXPAND
LOBBYING TO INCLUDE EFFORTS. AND
FOR THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WAS NEVER INTENDED TO
EXCLUDE LOBBYING FROM THE
DEFINITION WAR TO LIMIT PUBLIC
DISCLOSURES. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION ON RECORD ON THIS
BILL- THIS COMMITTEE WE- URGED
VOTE YES AND SEND IT TO THE
BALLOT SO THAT VOTERS CAN. VOICE
THEIR OPINION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT TO EXPAND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BY APPLYING
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS TO THESE
TYPES OF MURDERS- IN MY-
PREVIOUS LIFE I ALSO WORK ON
HEALTHCARE ISSUES I MOSTLY DO
LITIGATION ONGOOD GOVERNMENT
ISSUES NOW BUT- SAT THROUGH A
LOT OF HEARINGS ON INSURANCE
COMPANY MERGERS IN KENTUCKY
ABOUT. THAT IF YOU WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
DRIVER THANK YOU MISS PLANNING-
WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO SING
THE REGISTERED OPPOSITION WILL
NOT SORT OF MEMBERS- PRESENT%
HERE IN THIS HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYBODY. WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE. AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL. THE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ARE DRAWN BALENCIAGA'S
SERVICE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR THE INSTITUTE OF
GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES WERE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE HAVE NO
POSITION BUT JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFFS WORK IN THE
AUTHOR STAFFS WORK TO FOCUS ON-
TAYLOR THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. SAYING NO OTHER
PERSONS PRESENT IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WILL NOW OVER THE PHONE
LINES MISTRANSLATED WE HAVE. IN
THAT IN THE FALL MONTHS WISHES
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
IT'LL BE ONE MOMENT WITH THE
CRUISE LINE. WELL FIRST ALONG
WITH THIRTY FOR YOU WE CAN HERE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI CURRENT
LANGUAGE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT IS LINE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GOOD TERRACE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK FORTY ONE WE CAN
HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE. AT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S THE AUTHOR THE
BILL. ONE EIGHTY FIVE WE WILL
HAVE. A FEW. HELLO. I'M A
PASADENA RESIDENT NUMBER A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER OF PASADENA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BLANK TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CONTRAST GO LONGER NUMBER
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN HE WAS CLEAR. THANK YOU MISTER OPERATOR WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IS ANYBODY WISHING TO.
COMMENT QUESTIONER- RAISING
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE- MISS LEVINE
YOU MAY NOW CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU- TELL THE
WITNESSES- PROVIDING TESTIMONY
AND PHONING IN- TO BE A PART OF
THIS I'M A- I'M A CASA BLANKA
FAN AND- YOU KNOW I THINK THOSE
OF US TO KNOW THAT MOVIE- KINDA
LAUGH AT THE SCENE. WHERE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A DENIAL THAT
GAMBLING IS TAKING PLACE AT
RICK'S CAFE AND I'VE I WAS
ELECTED A DECADE AGO TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND I JUST FELT
EXTRAORDINARILY NAIVE TO KNOW.
THAT LOBBYISTS ARE ABLE TO MAKE
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR PAYDAYS ON
DECISIONS OF GOVERNMENT AND THIS
IS A ONE SMALL BILL TO GET AT
THAT I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND RESPECT LAST FOR
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS LEVINE-
GIVEN THE BROAD. SOCIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF INSURANCE
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS- A
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY. AND THE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL PROCESS OF THOSE
TRANSACTIONS I ALSO APPRECIATE
OFFERS EFFORTS TO NARROW THIS
BILL IN RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS
OF PRIOR VERSIONS WITH MOTION BY
MISTER LEE IN THE SECOND BY
MISTER BENNETT. MADISON WE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN. BRIAN I
SEYARTO. BENNETT I LOW NO I
MAYES E. LEAI BLANCA RUBIO ONE
CAN RUBIO I. THE BILLS OUT I
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. WELCOME
BACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES- AND GIVEN THE QUICK
SUPPORT I'LL KEEP THIS SHORT-
THE GOOD START BY THING THE
COMMITTEES CONSOLE MARKET
COMMITTEE SHORT IT'S ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BIT COMPLICATED I LIKE TO
START BY THING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR HER THOROUGH
ANALYSIS IN THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENT ON THE TOP OF PAGE
NINE REGARDING THE CONSOLIDATION
OF ELECTIONS I'M HAPPY THAT. I'M
IN. SEVEN MONTHS AGO CALIFORNIA
VOTERS GOING TO THE POLLS
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT TO
RECALL GOVERNOR NEWSOM- THE
GOVERNOR SOUNDLY DEFEATED THE
RECALL AND THAT BEGIN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE PROCESS
ESTABLISHED BY VOTERS OVER ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. THE COMMITTEE
WHEN THE HEARINGS- RECORD HE
WENT INTO HEARING RECALL REFORM
HEARINGS RECOGNIZING THE VALUE
OF THE RECALL PROCESS AND THE
NEED TO RETAIN THE SIMPLE. HOLD
ELECTED OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE
BUT WE ALSO HEARD OF THE NEED
FOR SOME PROCEDURAL STATUTORY
REFORMS ACCORDINGLY AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WOULD DO IT A
NUMBER OF THINGS IT WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER RECALL
PROPONENTS NECESSARY TO INITIATE
THE RECALL PROCESS. IT WOULD
EXTEND THE STANDARDS FOR
ACCURACY AND REVIEW OF
CANDIDATES STATEMENTS TO THE
STATEMENT OF REASONS BY RECALL
PROPONENTS AND THE ANSWER FROM
THE ELECTED OFFICIAL TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT INACCURATE OR
FALSE STATEMENTS BY EITHER THE
RECALL PROPONENTS OR- IN A BY
THE ELECTED OFFICIAL. WOULD
PROVIDE PERSPECTIVE RECALL
PETITION SIGNERS WITH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY IN SCHOOL DISTRICT
RELATED RECALLS BY REQUIRING THE
PETITIONS LISTS THE ESTIMATED
COST TO THE DISTRICT. WILL
PROVIDE GREATER EFFICIENCY IN
THE TIMING OF ELECTIONS AND
MINIMIZE LOCAL AGENCY ELECTION
COSTS BY ALLOWING MORE TIME TO
CONSOLIDATE A RECALL A STATE OR
LOCAL. BRING WITHIN ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS. BECAUSE THE RECALL
PROCESS IS SO IMPORTANT I DON'T
WANT TO WAIT INTO THIS ISSUE
LIGHTLY. I DON'T WAITED ISSUE.
AND WOULD APPRECIATE FEEDBACK IF
FOLKS HAVE CONCERNS OR THINK
THEIR POTENTIAL PIECES MISSING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN WITH ME TODAY ARE CALL
CARLOS MACHADO. LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR OPEN SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION. AND MAKE A TOOL THE
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE LOSS
ALAMEDA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
. THANK YOU. FOR THE RETURN.
HOME OF A PERSON OKAY- GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BRIAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARLOS MACHADO AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. OUT WHERE THE
SPONSOR OF THE AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR. THE BILL WOULD HELP
INCREASE VOTER PARTICIPATION
RECALL PETITION PROCESS- WHILE
PROVIDING SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
CRITICALLY NEEDED FLEXIBILITY TO
MINIMIZE ELECTION COSTS. MANY
DISTRICTS HAVE REACHED OUT TO
CSPA REGARDING THE IMPACT THAT.
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH RECALL
ELECTIONS ARE HAVING ON THEIR
STUDENTS. IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
ELECTION COSTS RANGE FROM THE
HIGH TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS. PER SMALLER
DISTRICTS THESE COSTS CAN WREAK
HAVOC. FORTUNATELY MANY VOTERS
ARE NOT AWARE THAT THESE COSTS
ARE BORNE BY THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND COULD REDUCE SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS. AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR ENSURES THAT
THE INFORMATION PRESENTED TO
VOTERS BY THE PROPONENTS AND THE
OFFICIAL SOUGHT TO BE RECALLED
IS ACCURATE AND TRUE. THE BILL
ALSO MAKES IT CLEAR TO VOTERS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RESULTING
ELECTION COSTS. GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL DISTRESS THAT
THESE ELECTIONS CAN HAVE ON
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THE BILL ALSO
INSURERS BROADER VOTER SENTIMENT
IS REFLECTED IN THE DECISION TO
INITIATE A RECALL. ADJUSTING THE
NUMBER OF SIGNATURES ON THE
NOTICE OF INTENTION WILL HELP
CURB ITS MISUSE WHEN ONLY AS FEW
AS TEN SIGNATURES ARE CURRENTLY
NEEDED TO MAKE IT OFFICIAL. TO
HELP DISTRICTS MINIMIZE ELECTION
COSTS THE BILL EXPANDS THE
PERIOD DURING WHICH A SPECIAL
ELECTION MAY BE CONSOLIDATED
WITH A LOCAL OR STATE ELECTION.
THIS CHANGE WILL HELP DISTRICTS
SAVE AS MUCH AS HALF OR MORE ON
ELECTION RELATED EXPENSES.
MOREOVER BY COMBINING THE
SPECIAL ELECTION WITH OTHER
ELECTIONS AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR. FOR HOPING FOR THE
PARTICIPATION IN DECISIONS THAT
WILL AFFECT THE EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR TODAY I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YES OKAY I'M GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BRIAN AN HONOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY SAYING AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL AND A CITIZEN THAT I DO
SUPPORT A RECALL PROCESS IT'S
PART OF OUR DEMOCRACY BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE PROCESS
CANNOT BE ADJUSTED- I WOULD MY
NAME IS MAY COULD TOTALLY AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE LOS ALAMEDA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH IS
LOCATED IN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN SIXTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES I WAS FIRST ELECTED TO
THE LOS AMIGOS. IN TWO THOUSAND
I AM NOW SERVING MY TWENTY
SECOND YEAR AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND I HAVE BEEN ELECTED
TO THIS POSITION SIX TIMES AND
EARLIER THIS YEAR I DID RECEIVE
A NOTICE OF INTENT TO ALL THE
LONG WITH TWO OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS IT ONLY TOOK TEN TO SIGN
THE PETITION TO INITIATE THIS
PROCESS IN MY SITUATION THE
RECALL GROUP WAS NOT VERY
ORGANIZED AND THEY COULD NEVER
COMPLETE THEIR- SIGNATURE
GATHERING PETITION CORRECT THEY
SELL MY RECALL JUST KIND OF WENT
AWAY I GUESS I WAS LUCKY. THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY OTHER RECALL IN
ORANGE COUNTY TO DATE NONE OF
THEM HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL BUT
THIS IS A THREAT THAT EVERY
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER IN THE STATE
IS AWARE OF MANY BOARD MEMBERS
ARE WONDERING WHY THEY ARE
WORKING SO HARD SO THAT ALL
CHILDREN CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN
LIFE ONLY TO BE FACED WITH THE
THREAT OF RECALL BECAUSE SOMEONE
DOES NOT LIKE A DECISION THEY
HAVE MADE THIS IS LEADING TO A
LOSS OF EXPERIENCE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS AND MANY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS WILL
IMPACT THE FUTURE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OUR CHARGE IS TO
EIGHT. GENERATION OF POIGNANT.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY FAIRNESS
AND HELP TO MAKE RECALLS BETTER
WAY TO REFLECT BETTER REFLECTION
WITH A MUCH LARGER VOTER.
TURNOUT THE REASONABLE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BILL TO THE
MINIMUM SIGNATURES REQUIRED FOR
A NOTICE OF INTENTION WILL HELP
YOU. WHAT WOULD HELP LIMIT IT
USED FOR THE PURPOSE AND- THEN
WHAT IS INTENDED. THE PUBLIC
REVIEW AND RIP PROCESS OF THE
BILL WILL ENSURE VOTERS ARE
PROVIDED WITH ACCURATE AND
TRUTHFUL INFORMATION IN THE
PROPONENT STATEMENT. AND THE
OFFICE HOLDER WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A BOARD MEMBER WHO IS IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING RECALLED. AND
IS BEING AND THE REASONS FOR HIS
RECALLS THAT HE WAS NOT LEGALLY
ELECTED. AND THAT HE STARTED THE
MASK MANDATE HE DID NOT DO THE
MASS MANDATE ANOTHER PERSON TO
IT AND HE WAS ALMOST RECALL BUT
IN FACT I CAN GO. AND HE WAS
LEGALLY- ELECTED BECAUSE NO ONE
ELSE FILED PAPERS AND ACCORDING
TO ELECTION LAWS IF YOU'RE THE
ONLY PERSON WHO FILES FOR A
POSITION. YOU GET IT BUT HE IS
FACING RECALL ON TWO VERY ARONIE
US- ISSUES. THIS BILL ALSO
ENABLE SCHOOL DISTRICT REDUCE
THE RECALL COSTS BY CONSENT
CONSOLIDATING THE ELECTIONWITH
OUR LOCAL AND STATE ELECTIONS.
THIS HELPS REDUCE THE TOTAL
ELECTION EXPENSES FOR THE SCOTT
FOR ALL THE SCHOOLS AND AS PART
OF THIS BILL. IN THIS ALSO
ALLOWS VOTERS. RESPECT WE GONNA
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO WRAP IT UP.
OKAY- I JUST OKAY- I JUST I HAD
. PASSING AB EIGHTY. WILL BE
ABLE TO OUR SCHOOL THIS AND
ARCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MONEY. I DO ONE PRIMARY ENOUGH.
OR AND HE THE ARE YOU HERE TODAY
. IF ADAM FOR. WHAT DO THAT JUST
A SECOND. BONTA RAISES ONE SURE
TWO MINUTES I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADJUST THE THIS
COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFUL BUT YOU
KNOW THE SCHOOL BOARDS IN THE
STATE THROUGHOUT THE NATION HAVE
FOUND THEMSELVES HAVE FOR IT
FACING STRONG OPPOSITION FROM
PARENTS SO WHEN YOU HAVE A
CONFLICT BETWEEN PARENTAL
INTEREST AND THE SCHOOL BOARDS
THE ONLY. MECHANISM THE PARENTS
HAVE TO HOLD THE SCHOOL BOARDS
ACCOUNTABLE IS TO FIRE THEM IF
THEY DON'T DO THEIR JOB IF THEY
DON'T REPRESENT THEIR TRUE
INTERESTS AND THAT'S THE RECALL
PROCESS AND THAT'S WHAT IT WAS
ESTABLISHED FOR I DO AGREE WITH
ONE ASPECT OF THE BILL. AND
THAT'S FOR YOUR IT AND FACTUAL
MASON ON BOTH OF THE PARTIES
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR IN FACT A
MADE SOME YOU KNOW SOME MIS
INFORMATION AND ALLEGATIONS THAT
WERE NOT TRUE ON HIS STATEMENT
AND I YOU KNOW. I DO AGREE WITH
THAT THERE COMPONENTS TO THIS
THAT IT'S A LENGTHY BILL I CAN'T
GO INTO IT I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
TIME BUT- IT DOES NEED TO BE
AMENDED HEAVILY. THANK YOU FOR
TAP THANK. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO-
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
ORGANIZATION POSITION ON THE
BILL. HI GOOD MORNING I'M
CHAIRMAN BRIAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE YVONNE COUNTRY ON
BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. THANKS SO MUCH SEE NO OTHER.
PERSONS IN THE ROOM WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY. FOUR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AT THIS TIME. THE MOBILE FIRST.
LINE EIGHTY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HEY IS THAT ME. IT IS
MEANT IT IT SEEMS TO ME THIS
BILL IS NOT GETTING EQUAL
REPRESENTATION YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
SECOND WITNESS MAY NOT
ORGANIZATION. THE FIRM WE SAW
YOU WERE. AND WILL. AND WE'RE
SICK OF YOU NICE PERSON. ON
FORTY ONE GOING. TO AS THE
PARENT STATE. I'D LIKE TO BE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH INSTEAD YOU DON'T
KNOW WHY GROUP MEMBERS ARE.
BEING THREE. WHY EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD MS NAME AND-
HEATHER KELLER THAT'S COUNTY
PROUD RICO NEED SOMEBODY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE STRELA I WOULD
SACRAMENTO COUNTY COORDINATOR
FOR THE RECALL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHIEF CHESSON VIEW AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN CONSIDER STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHEROKEE WAS
QUICKER. THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER. AND LAWS
EVERYBODY CALL. IT WILL NOW TURN
OVER TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS CONCERNS COMMENTS FOR
THE OFFICE. THREE SENATE THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAN I WAS THE
CHAMP SECOND THANK I THINK IT'S
ONLY BERMAN FOR TO WORK ON THE
SO I DEFINITELY THINK THAT
CONSOLIDATING THE LOCAL
ELECTIONS TO MORE REGULAR
SCHEDULE ACTION IS LAW SENSE
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
WEAPONIZATION OF RECALLS OF
COURSE. AND FORTUNATUS EVEN.
TRICKLES OUT EVEN TO LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD RACES WHERE
UNFORTUNATES OVER RACES EVEN A
ROLL CALIFORNIA AND URBAN
CALIFORNIA ARE BEING WEAPONIZED
SO. AT OVER REALLY I THINK-
EVERY DEVICE UGLY ISSUES SO IT'S
REALLY THOUGHTFUL PUT THAT
INSIDE AS WE GOT TO SEE THAT
COUPLE TO PUT INTO THIS GREATER
REFORM AND HAS A LOT OF
ATTENTION IN THE MEDIA TO TALK
TO THE STATE RECALL THE RECALL
THE GOVERNOR STUFF BUT- LOCAL
SERVICE OF SOME FORMS OF ID
INCLUDE THAT SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU. THE
BILL. THANK YOU ARMS BERMAN I
ALSO AS A FOR SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I KNOW HOW THE BY OF
SCHOOL ARE- THE MONEY THAT'S
BEING SPENTON SOMETIMES
FRIVOLOUS- RECALL- EFFORTS-
REALLY DO TAKE AWAY FROM THE
MONEY THAT'S- AVAILABLE TO THE
KIDS IN THE CLASSROOM AND YOU
KNOW IF IT'S A IN THE ISSUE-
THEN I COMPLETELY AGREE USE THE
RECALL PROCESS BUT IT IS BEING
WEAPONIZED TO THE POINT WHERE
SOMETIMES AS SOON AS THE ONE WE
CALL- EFFORT FAILS THE NEXT DAY
HE FELL AND NEXT ONE. AND SOLD
SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO MANAGE- THE
ABILITY FOR THE PEOPLE TO SPEAK
BUT ALSO NOT TO WEAPONIZE THESE
ISSUES I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
ABOUT THANK. IT'S BEEN. A I A
HAPPY HAVE BEEN WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN ON A
SERIES OF THESE RECALL OF.
ISSUES AND- CERTAINLY THIS IS
ONE OF THE KEY STEPS MOVING
FORWARD WITH AND DID PART OF THE
PACKAGE- WE AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE POINTED OUT RECALLS HAVE
CHANGED. AND THEY'RE BEING
WEAPONIZED FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES NOT FOR. THE REGIONAL
TENT OF- THE AUTHORS OF THE
CONSTITUTION- AND FORTUNATELY
SOME OF THE THINGS WE CAN DO
WITHOUT CHANGING THE
CONSTITUTION AND SOME OF THEM
WILL REQUIRE. A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS BUT IT'S GOOD TO GET
IT ALL DONE THIS YEAR- IN A
SERIES OF BILLS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE- FOURTH AND- ASILO
HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL WITH. THE AT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF ONE SO ALSO COME HOURS A
SCHOOL MEMBER YOUR YEARS OF
SERVICE. WE VALUE YOUR SERVICE
AND MANY WILL KNOW THAT SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS AS ALMOST LIKE A
VOLUNTEER BASIS. AND OFTEN TIMES
IS MORE FINANCIALLY COSTLY JUST
GIVEN THE COMMITMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS- BEING
PRESENT AND IT WAS JUST ACTUALLY
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO THAT.
ASSEMBLY BERMAN I DID SIT DOWN
WITH A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER WHO
REPRESENTED. A PARTS OF
SUNNYVALE WHO SAID THAT SHE WAS
TARGETED. OF A SIMILAR RECALL.
AND THE DEVASTATION THAT IT TOOK
IN THE DISTRACTION FOR THE
DISTRICT AND THAT SHE ENCOURAGED
HER OWN PERSONAL COST. IN
RETAINING A COUNCIL- AND THE
DETRIMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND
SO AGAIN I THINK THAT CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING THIS CONVERSATION TO
OCCUR- TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS DIRECT. TIRE SIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE-
OUR APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND HOW WE CAN HELP
STRENGTHEN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DEMOCRACY AND TO THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU'D BE
SO KIND OF LOVE TO CO AUTHOR THE
LEGISLATION AS WELL. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR FIGHTING FOR
THOSE IN HELPING TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS THANK YOU MITCHELL. I
DON'T. SEVEN BERMAN MICHAEL. YET
JUST REALLY A- EVERYBODY
COMMENTS I HELP BUT NO THAT THE
COMMITTEES MUCH BETTER BEHAVED
NEW LEADERSHIP- SO I WANT TO
THINK THAT THE CHAIR FOR THAT-
BUT- NO I DID JUST YOU KNOW.
WITH THE RECALL PROCESS IS
IMPORTANT BUT IT BEING ABUSED WE
YOU KNOW MUST BE CORRECTED AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. ALLUDED TO
A COLLEGE ALL RIGHT A SCHOOL FOR
CALLING OF OURS. WHO I THINK
THREE RECALLS HAVE BEEN IN.
AGAINST HER DOES IT YOU KNOW
THAT IT WAS INITIATED IT FAILS A
WEEK LATER THE INITIATE ANOTHER
ONE IT FAILS A WEEK LATER THE
HAD YOU KNOW EAT IF THE A WEEK
LATER THE INITIATE ANOTHER ONE.
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE THAT'S
NOT THE PROPER PROCESS AND THAT
NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED IN. YELL
AT SOME RUBIO AND ENDED IN
DECEMBER LOW AND OTHERS YOU KNOW
MENTIONED THAT AND SCHOOL BOARD
I THINK IS THE HARDEST JOB IN
POLITICS. AND IN SO HONESTLY-
AND THEN SO WITH AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY CAN. DO
YOU DO WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
STUDENTS AND WHEN THEY'RE
DISTRACTED BY FOR FRIVOLOUS
RECALL ATTEMPTS- THAT THAT JUST
THE TRACKS FROM THE STUDENTS
ABILITY TO GET THE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE SO.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HERE- REALLY ONCE
RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU- LET CHAIR. ARMIN I A
SITUATION FOR THE I WAS ELECTED
HAD TO LOW CITY MEMBER AND OVER
CITY- A CITY MAN COUNCIL MEMBER
IN LOS ANGELES A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND SCORE MEMBERS ALL
BEING SERVED WITH INTENTIONS TO
BE RECALLED NONE OF THOSE
INTENTIONS GOT THE REQUIRED
SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY FOR THE
BALLOT- THEY WERE JUST LARGE
DISTRACTIONS THAT PREVENT FOLKS
FROM LEGISLATING EFFECTIVELY-
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO GET
BILL I'D BE HAPPY TO JUMP ON AS
A CO AUTHOR LOVE IT ASSUMING IT
PASSES THIS COMMITTEE I DON'T
KNOW PORT- OF THE CHAIR AND
THERE'S A MOTION TO MOVE BY
SOMETHING OVER BENNETT. SECONDED
BY MR LOW MADAM SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOST IS TO
PASS AS A MAN AND B. E. RIVER.
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN. BRIAN
SEYARTO. BENNETT BENNETT HI LO.
WELL I MAYES. LI LI I BLANCA
RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO I. THE BILL
IS OUT FOR ZERO EIGHT ONE THANKS
. THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY. NEXT ON
THE AGENDA WE'VE GOT MR. BEEN I.
DON'T KNOW. I'M ALSO TO- THE
GAVEL OVER TO MR LOAN
TEMPORARILY AND WE'VE ACTUALLY.
I THINK. THE STAFF RIGHT YEAH.
VARNISHED MEMBERS NO ONE START
BUY EXTRA THE- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- APPRECIATE THE WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THIS ABM
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY TWO SO VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD- MAJOR IT'S SIMP
SIMPLY SEEKS TO SIMPLIFY THE
LOCAL RECALL PROCESS- COMMITTEE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME REVIEWING
THE RECALL PROCESS I WORKED WITH
THE FORMER CHAIR- I HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM ABOUT
THIS- AND IT'S BEEN A CONCERN
FOR QUITE SOME TIME BECAUSE OF
SOME THINGS CAN BE DONE-
WITHOUT- A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
AND AMENDING THE CONSTITUTION-
WILL WE HAVE TO SORT OF
COLLECTIVELY DECIDED ON A
STRATEGY OF PUTTING FORWARD A-
NUMBER OF BILLS TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE- AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWO. HAS THE FOLKS THE VOTERS
FOCUS ON THE RECALL ONLY AND NOT
DEALING WITH THE CONFUSION OF
WHO WERE ALL THE REPLACEMENT
CANDIDATES ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
THAT OUT ONE OF THE BIG THINGS
THAT- I'M TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT AS MORE MORE
WEALTH GETS CONCENTRATED IN THE
HANDS OF THE SMALLER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PEOPLE ARE WEAPONIZING
THE RECALL CAMPAIGN AND PEOPLE
ARE USING THE RECALL CAMPAIGN TO
GET THEMSELVES ELECTED- AND- WE
HAVE A CLASSIC EXAMPLE- IN THE
CITY OF OXNARD LARGEST CITY AND
COUNTY OF INTER A- A CHARACTER
COULD NOT WIN IN THE REGULAR
ELECTION IMMEDIATELY LAUNCHES A
RECALL AGAINST ALL FOUR PEOPLE-
ON THE CITY COUNCIL- AND- NONE
OF THOSE ARE SUCCESSFUL- BUT
CLEARLY THE INDIVIDUAL WAS
TRYING TO SEE IF THEY COULD PULL
OFF BY RECALL WHAT THEY COULDN'T
PULL. HI IN THE GENERAL ELECTION
SO THIS BILL I THINK IT'S JUST
GOOD GOVERNMENT YOU'VE YOUR
FOCUS ON THE RECALL AND IF THE
PERSON DOES GET RECALLED YOU
TREAT IT JUST LIKE ANYTHING ELSE
WHICH IS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HAS AND CAN CREATE WHATEVER
PROCEDURES THEY WANT TO TRY TO
FILL THAT IN BUT IT DOESN'T
ALLOW SOMEBODY TO AUTOMATICALLY
USE. RECALL TO. HOPPED OF
ANOTHER FOR THE- FOR- ELECT TO
THAT. C. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BENNETT. MIGHT THERE BE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE- ROOMS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS TIME
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY TWO. THANK MISTER
CHAIR FOR SUPPORT FOR TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY TWO PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THIS CHAIR WITH NO
RESPONSE FROM A PROMPT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR. NOW
ON TO OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWO. SEEING NONE OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. BERAPA PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE GOING TO ALIGN
NUMBER FORTY ONE FORTY YEAR OLD
PEOPLE AT SIX. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN- WILL BRING ONE MY NAME
IS MARCH AND I'M AFTER JERSEY
FOR. AND PLASTER COUNTY AND- WE
ARE IN STRONG UP. AS ANY BILL
THAT INFRINGES UPON OUR RECALL
ELECTIONS THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
THE LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THAT'S A
STEP IN THE SUELEN AND- THAT
WORD WEAPONIZE YOU CONTINUE TO
USE THIS IS NOT A WEAPON IT'S A
HUNDRED AND TEN YEAR OLD LAW
THAT WE HAVE A WHITE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HELLO NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PUBLIC NINETY
THAT'S ME- STEVE ON JUNE STROKES
OF THIS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHEROKEE WAS QUICKER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR OPERATIVE NOW MOVES
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. AND OR A
MOTION. THE MOVE. CAME MOTION
BY- MISTER LEE'S SECOND BY THIS
REVIEW. SUMMER BENNETT DO WISH
TO CLOSE THE JEFF JUST TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS A COMPANION TO
THE BILL THAT WE JUST APPROVED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN- WE
WORK TOGETHER TO- PULL THIS OFF
IN TERMS OF CHANGES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER BENNETT THERE THERE IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION BY THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR. AND WITH THAT
CAN THE SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BRIAN. SEYARTO BENNETT
HI SENATE I LOW ALL RIGHT NOW I
MAYES LEAVE ME I WANT TO RUBIO.
YOU I. FOUR ZERO THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MAY HAD ON. OKAY THIS WE
DON'T CURRENTLY SEE ANY
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS AT THIS TIME
WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS THERE MOTION. THE
MOTION BY LEASING BY MISTER
BENNETT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HELLO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY ONE BUY CERVANTES
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
BIGELOW. AND AB. TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS. BRIAN SEYARTO BENNETT
I BENNETT I LOW BY WELL I MINIS
PLEASE LEAVE I BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS.
AT THE.
CAN BE MEMBERS WERE JUST WAITING
FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHOR WHO IS ON
HIS WAY.
AND IF. COOLEY SAID THAT THE
WE'VE JUST A QUORUM AS WELL
LET'S GO TO TAKE UP A FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY AT THE CHAIR
HAS AN OPPOSE RECOMMENDATION. IS
THERE A MOTION. SOME OF THE-
MOTION. AND I WILL SECOND
SOPORIFIC ABLE TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION ON AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY BY SOME A MEMBER
WHEN IS TO PASSAND BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN. SEYARTO
BENNETT. BENNETT NO LOW HI LOW I
MAYES LEE B. NO BLANCA RUBIO ONE
RUBIO NOT LOADING. THE BILL IS
ON CALL. AND COLLEAGUES WHICH IS
WAITING FOR. ADDITIONAL AUTHOR.
FOR- OKAY WE HAVE. TWO PEOPLE
OKAY- I DON'T KNOW IF THE WHAT
THE HELL. PEOPLE HERE. IT
DOESN'T. MAKE MR BIGELOW
WELCOMED YEAH THIS IS. FROM
POINT TO THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIVE TWO EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LITTLE OUT OF
BREATH I THINK WE'RE ALL PLAYING
MUSICAL CHAIRS TODAY RUNNING
BACK AND FORTH. FIRST OF ALL I
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
STAFF- BOTH HERE AT THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL AND M. AND MY
STAFF FOR WORKING SO- WELL
TOGETHER. WITH EVERYONE IN
TRYING TO BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD- TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT- TO THE COMMITTEE AND
AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT- MOTION THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO EXTEND THE MISSION OF
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT BY
MAKING IT EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC
TO FIND INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
MONEY INFLUENCES CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WAS PASSED SHORTLY
AFTER THE WATERGATE SCANDAL WHEN
GOVERNMENT SKEPTICISM WAS HIGH
ACROSS THIS NATION. THE ACT WAS
DESIGNED TO PUT AN END TO THE
CORRUPTION BY REQUIRING
DISCLOSURE ABOUT THE ROLE OF
MONEY IN POLITICS. TO THIS DAY
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT IS HELD
IN HIGH REGARD. BECAUSE IT
OFFERS MORE TRANSPARENCY IN OUR
GOVERNMENT. CURRENTLY DEPENDING
UPON THE TYPE OF CANDIDATE OR
ELECTED OFFICIAL RUNNING.
LOCATING CAMPAIGN STATEMENTS CAN
BE EASIER SAID THAN DONE THOUGH
. ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
CANDIDATES WHETHER THEY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CITIES
COUNTIES OR STATE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT THRESHOLDS OF FILING
AND FILING LOCATIONS WHICH CAN
MAKE FINDING INFORMATION
DIFFICULT FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT AIMS TO EXTEND THIS
MISSION OF POLITICAL REFORM ACT
OF THE PREFER POLITICAL REFORM
ACT BY CREATING A ONE PUBLIC
LOCATION ON THE SECRETARY OF
STATE THE STATE'S WEBSITE CAL
EXCESS. IN WHICH CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS SHOWING UP FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE CAN BE
FOUND REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OR
CANDIDATE THE SECRETARY THE
STATE IS CURRENTLY WORKING TO
UPDATE THE CALYX AND SYSTEM AS
WE'RE ALL AWARE IN IN. HOPEFUL
THAT IT'LL GET DONE IN A IN A
TIMELY WAY. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS DRAFTED BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY THE FOLLOWING
JANUARY REGARDING THEIR ABILITY
TO IMPLEMENT LOCAL CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURE REPORTS IN THE CALYX
AS A REPLACEMENT SYSTEM. IS
FURTHER CLARIFIED THAT THE
REPORT WILL BE DONE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
FINALLY THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
WILL BE OPERATIVE A YEAR AFTER
THE SECRETARY STATE CERTIFIES
THE CHANGES TO THE SYSTEM. THAT
THE SYSTEM CAN BE ACCOMMODATED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
BIGELOW FOR ALSO A PRESENTING
AND ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
SEE NON OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE.
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
WANT TO MAKE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
NINE ZERO- WE HAVE NO RESPONSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR
NOW TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. SINAN
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT.
PROPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE START. ALTHOUGH NOT
ALIGNMENT NUMBER FORTY LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE. HELLO THERE
MEMBERS. YES OUR TAXES ARE
WANTING TO SPEAK IN- SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THE MONEY MR LATCHAM
AND- FOR DAVID BRADLEY RUNNING
U. S. SENATE THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN MR ADDITIONAL RESPONDENTS
COMPUTE THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- BUT WILL HAVE GO TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SUMMARILY
. ASSEMBLY BIGELOW AYE
APPRECIATE THIS BILL APPRECIATE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY AND I THINK THE
DIRECTION OF THE BILLS REALLY
GOOD BUT IS THE ONUS ON FILING
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ON THE
CANDIDATE EVEN AFTER THESE.
AMENDMENTS THAT DON IS ON THE-
CANDIDATE IS TO MAKE THE
REPORTING- THE PURVIEW. AT THAT
SECRETARY THE STATE'S AT THAT
TIME. SO THEY WOULD STILL BE
FIGHTING THE BUT FACES I JUST
WONDERING SINCE OBVIOUSLY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE TO RECEIVE THE
SAME PAPERWORK. WHY WAS IT
TENSION TO PUT ON THE CANDIDATE
NOT SAY THE LOCAL FILING
JURISDICTION COULD THEY SAID
IT'S A GREAT STATE. THE OWNERS
AT THE END OF THIS WHEN THIS
BILL IS AN- ENFORCED WE'LL JUST
GO TO THE SECRETARY OF THE
STATE. THEY WON'T HAVE TO DO
DUPLICATE WORK. RIGHT SO I WAS
WONDERING WHY NOT HAVE THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION BUT THE COUNTY
CLERK FILE IT TO SECURE THE
INSTEAD OF THE- CANDIDATE.
BECAUSE CANDIDATES
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THE
RECORDING I'M NOT NOT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITY SPEAKING OKAY.
OUR GOAL THANK YOU FOR ANSWER
QUESTION I JUST THINK. IT JUST
MAKES A LOT SENSE ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THOSE TINY RACES WHERE
PEOPLE AREN'T VERY FAMILIAR WITH
ALL THE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
ORIGINALLY. THAT NOT EVERYONE IS
A STEEP IN CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW
BUT THEY SHOULD STILL HAVE. CAN
BE DISCLOSURES MADE AVAILABLE WE
JUST WANT PEOPLE TO- NOT FOUND
HIS DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO DO CELLS
THAT'S WHILE IT'S I'M MORE PRONE
AND HAVING TO LOCAL JURISDICTION
FILE IF POSSIBLE. I'M SO HAPPY
IT'S PORTABLE TO MS PEOPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PREDICT
THOSE COMMENTS ASSEMBLY RUBEN
YEAH. I HAVE SOME DIRECT
EXPERIENCES COUNTY SUPERVISOR
WITH THIS ISSUE- AND AS A
SUGGESTION OF ACT. OFFER AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD ASSUMING IT.
DOES MOVE FORWARD- IS WE ENDED
UP MAKING IT A RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE CANDIDATE AND THAT'S
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE CLERKS HE
HAD A DOUBLE RESPONSIBILITY
THERE- WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT
THE CLERKS WERE- BUT- YOU KNOW
BOTH WERE. BURKE HOPING SOMEBODY
ELSE WOULD DO IT- IN AND- IT FOR
VARIETY OF REASONS I THINK YOU
MAKE A GOOD POINT. THE CLERK. IF
THE CLERK HAS REACHED. MAKE
EVERYTHING FILED THEM SHOWS UP.
AND THEY- ALSO KNOW THE-
CANDIDATE HAS A RESPONSE. IT'S A
CANDIDATE FOR SOME THIS SURE
THAT. BUT THE- PAPERWORK IS
FILED. THEN THE CLERK SHOULD
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY TO SOMEHOW
MAKE SURE THAT THAT GETS ON THE
SUBJECT IT'S A JET SUGGESTION
THOUGH- THAT OF. AFTER HAVING
SOME INTERACTIONS ON THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE I'VE TRIED HAVE
ELECTRONIC FILING- WEEK WE CAME
UP WITH SO. FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. WELL I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AND
ARE THERE WELL TAKEN AND I'LL
I'LL DEFINITELY TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AS- YOU AND I BOTH HAD
EXPERIENCE BEING COUNTY
SUPERVISORS. YOU KNOW I SPENT
TWELVE YEARS DOING IT AND IT
IT'S IT. IT IS A CHALLENGING
YOU'RE RIGHT NOBODY REALLY WANTS
TO TAKE CARE OF IT BUT- IT HAS
TO BE DONE AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THE HONEST. THE REASON THAT AT
ANY LENGTH FOR THIS ELECTRONIC
FILING HAS SO MANY BENEFITS FOR
THE GENERAL PUBLIC- THAT IT'S-
SO MANY. THANK YOU MUCH FOR THAT
SIX. WELCOME BACK MISTER CHAIR
WE CROSSED PATHS.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER I'M SORRY
I MISSED YOUR PRESENTATION BUT I
KNOW THIS BILL WELL WE TALKED
LATE INTO THE EVENING ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY READ IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
APPRECIATED THAT IS THAT'S ALL
THE TEMA AND YOUR TEAM AS WELL-
THIS BILL DOES HAVE MY SUPPORT
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE WE
HAVE A SECOND. MESSAGE I CAN
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN- BRIAN I
SEYARTO HI SEYARTO AYE BENNETT
AYE BENNETT AYE LOW. LOW I MAYES
LEAVE. LEVY I BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO I. SIX SIX ZERO
SOME OF THE BILLS OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS AND THE
STRUCTURE. AND AGAIN TO THE
STAFF THANKS SO MUCH.
FOR
SO NEXT UP WE- A EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT. BY CHAIR MISTER BRIAN.
WHEN YOU'RE READY. MISTER VICE
CHAIR- AND COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
WHEN THE CENTER BUREAU COUNTY
WITH PART OF THE SENTENCE
COUNTED CARCERI TO PEOPLE AS
RESIDENTS AT THE PRISON WE THEY
ARE INCARCERATED RATHER THAN AS
PART OF THEIR HOME COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE CENSUS DATA IS USED FOR
DRAWING THE LINES POLITICAL
BOUNDARIES THIS PRACTICE
DISTORTS REPRESENTATION AT LOCAL
AND STATE LEVELS. IN TWENTY
ELEVEN LEGISLATOR PROVED AB FOR
TWENTY BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIKE DAVIS WHICH SOUGHT TO END
THIS PRACTICE WHICH IS SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS PRISON
GERRYMANDERING. BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS CREATED A
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION AND GAVE IT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR REDISTRICTING
OF CONGRESSIONAL LEGISLATIVE AND
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION DISTRICTS
AB FOUR TWENTY REQUESTED THE
COMMISSION TO TREAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AS RESIDING IN THEIR HOME
COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN AT THE
PRISONS WHERE THEY ARE
INCARCERATED WHEN ADOPTING
DISTRICT LINES. IN JANUARY OF
LAST YEAR AFTER A GREAT DEAL OF
STUDY AND DISCUSSION THE
COMMISSION UNANIMOUS. TO COMPLY
WITH THIS REQUEST. AS THE
DIGITAL LINES. DID BY THE
COMMISSION LAST DECEMBER MARKED
THE FIRST TIME THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATIVE CONGRESSIONAL AND
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION DISTRICTS
WERE NOT DISTORTED. DUE TO
PRISON J. MAN ADDITIONALLY LAST
SESSION LEGISLATOR PROVED TO
BILLS TO ELIMINATE PRISON
GERRYMANDERING AND LOCAL
REDISTRICTING. SINCE COMPLETING
ITS LINE DRAWING ACTIVITIES IN
DECEMBER THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION HAS
BEEN REFLECTING ON ITS WORK.
OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
AND WORKING TO IDENTIFY
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES THAT IT
SUPPORTS OF THE BODY. ONE CHANGE
AT THE COMMISSION VOTED TO
SUPPORT IS CHANGING STATE LAW TO
REQUIRE. THAT INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS BE DEEMED RESIDENTS
OF THEIR LAST KNOWN PLACES OF
RESIDENCE. FOR ALL FUTURE STATE
REDISTRICTING PROCESSES. AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT MAKES THAT
CHANGE. IN FORTY EIGHT MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
ELECTIONS GO TO REFLECT THE FACT
THAT LEGISLATOR NO LONGER HAS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ADOPTING
DISTRICT LINES FOR THE
LEGISLATOR CONGRESS AND BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION. ALTHOUGH THE
CITIZENS REDUCTION COMMISSION IS
NOT TAKING A POSITION ON THE
EXACT LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL MY
OFFICE IS WORKING INCREDIBLY
CLOSELY WITH AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO AT THIS BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT HAS
THE SUPPORT OF THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS. OF CALIFORNIA AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION. LISA
FERNANDEZ ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION IS ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY. SO MAYES
SAID. FERNANDEZ HOW YOU I'M
SORRY. COMPLETED THAT'S PERFECT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. MISS
FERNANDEZ ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
GET THEM ON THE LINE OKAY
MISBRANDED GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MEDICARE MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M NINETY SEVEN AND
IT WAS NOTED EARLIER
COMMISSIONER ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT IMPORTANT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE BEFORE THE-
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT AMONG
OTHER CHANGES IMMENSE AND YOU
DIDN'T YOU CAN CHANGE IN THE LAW
REGARDING THE STATUS OF THE
STATE. STREET PURTON CALIFORNIA
PRESENT. IN THE CURRENT CODE
LANGUAGE THE LEGISLATURE
REQUESTS. THAT CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION COUNTY TWO CARS RATE
FOR SENATE AT HIS OR HER. LAST
KNOWN ADDRESS PRIOR TO
INCARCERATION. EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WHEN FED REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AGAINST
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION AFTER
EACH SPENT THAT ACCOUNT USING
CARTS RATE PERCENT AT HIS OR HER
LAST KNOWN DDRESS RATHER THAN
THE PLACE OF INCARCERATION THE
TWENTY TWENTY COMMISSION DID
JUST THAT X. SHARE BRIAN NOTED
THAT IT BELIEVES THAT MAKE SENSE
OF IT BEING AUTOMATIC RATHER
THAN A REQUEST FOR EACH FUTURE
COMMISSION TO DECIDE EVERY TEN
YEARS COUNTING EACH EQUESTRIAN
BUT THEN AT THE LAST MINUTE
DRESS MAKES FAR MORE SENSE AND
THE PICK OF INCARCERATION IN THE
LATTER OWN ONLY ARTIFICIALLY
DRIVES UP NUMBERS IN THE COUNTY
WITH THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
ADDITIONALLY INCARCERATED PERSON
IN NOT INTENDED A MAN IN A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION WHEN
DETERMINING RESIDENT STATUS THE
LAST NINETY CAR STRAIGHT PERSON
TO DRESS IS THE FAR FAIR
DETERMINATION TO COUNTY CORK
STRAIGHT PERSON RATHER THAN AT
THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY I
WOULD BE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. RIGHT I BELIEVE THAT'S THE
ONLY PRIMARY WITNESSED. CORRECT
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE PEOPLE
ROOM AND YOU IN THE ROOM. IN ONE
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
MEASURE. YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR SUPPORT THOROS THE
GIVEN VOTERS A CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. ANYBODY ELSE. ALL
RIGHT MISS EIGHTEEN G. OPERATOR
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES IS
THERE ANYBODY CALLING IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THE
PROPOSAL THE PHONE PRESS ONE
ZERO TWO VOICE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
. WE HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT TOGETHER
THOSE NUMBERS.
ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS MAX BERNIE
AND I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. IN THE STRUCTURE WOULD
HAVE NO PROBLEM RESPONDENTS IN
Q. OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA BRING HIM
BACK TO THE ROOM I BELIEVE THERE
ARE NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
CORRECT OKAY ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISH TO EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. SINCE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM WILL ONCE
AGAIN GO TO THE A. T. AND T.
LINE WE ALREADY HEARD FROM ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS- CAN YOU
PLEASE. OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE THE MEASURE. GIVE CHAIR
PROP. PRESS ONE ZERO WE DO HAVE
ONE THANK YOU ARE. FIND FORTY
THESE GOING- YES AND INDUSTRY
ONCE A REPRESENTS CHINCHA RALLY
RUNNING U. S. SENATE. AND WE'RE
AND WE'RE IN A ED OPPOSITION TO
STOP THANK YOU. STRUCTURE
CARRILLO FOR THE REST. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL VERY IT BACK TO
THE DÍAS FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
ANYBODY. GOOD BILL I MAY HAVE
ONE QUESTION. SO HOW ARE ARE IN
I HOPE YOU WITNESSES STILL ON
THE LINE HOW ARE ARE COLLEGE
STUDENTS. COUNTED ARE THEY
COUNTED AT THE COLLEGE THEIR OUT
WHILE TEY'RE THERE FOR. EIGHT
MONTHS. OR THEY COUNTED AT HOME
. AND QUITE LITERALLY DEPENDS ON
THE REGISTRATION AND THAT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY UP TO THE COLLEGE
STUDENTS- SO I IMAGINE WHERE THE
REGISTERED AT YEAH WE'RE THERE
TO WHERE THEY CHOOSE TO REGISTER
AT AS THE DOMICILE WHETHER
THEY'RE OUT OF STATE EVEN
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO. CONTINUE TO
VOTE I ELECTIONS- IN THEIR HOME
DOMICILE. SO IF THEY WISH TO BE
BECAUSE THEY THEY I UNDERSTAND
THE CITY'S ISSUES WITH THIS IS.
IT YOU KNOW. THEY WOULD LIKE
EVERYBODY PAST AND PRESENT TO BE
INCLUDED INTO THEIR ACCOUNTS
BECAUSE THEN THEY GET THAT THE
MONEY THAT THEY NEED- BUT AND
ALSO THE AREAS WHERE THE PRISONS
ARE LOCATED THEY ALSO NEED THAT
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
VERY PRESENCE OF THE PEOPLE ARE
IN. OUR ANY OF THE ANCILLARY
SERVICES AND STUFF SO THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF MY QUANDARY ON
THIS IS. IS YOU KNOW IF THE
TRUE- IDEA OF THIS IS TO COUNT
THE PERSON. YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE HAVING THE IMPACT FOR
THE TIME THAT THEY'RE HAVING
THAT IMPACT. IT'S LIKE HOW DO
YOU RECONCILE WHAT'S FAIR FOR.
WHO IS NOW YOU'RE COUNTING
SOMEBODY THAT YOU'RE REALLY NOT
SERVING. WHERE IS THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUFFERING THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OR- OFTEN ANOTHER AREA.
CABINETS ARE MY CLOTHES YEAH.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO OTHER DO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND I
BELIEVE WE HAD MR LEE AND MR
LOW- WHETHER MOTIONS SECOND SO
GO AHEAD AND NOW THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE ABSOLUTELY I THINK
GERRYMANDERING AND ALL OF ITS
FORMS DISTORTS THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS RIGHT IN IN THE MEANS OF
TO REPRESENTATION IRONICALLY I
RECENTLY VISITED A PRISON.
FOLSOM PRISON- HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I TALKED TO
SEVERAL PEOPLE NONE OF THEM FROM
THE SURROUNDING AREA AND
IRONICALLY ALL OF THEM FROM THE
CRENSHAW DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT- THERE IS A MIS
CALCULATION THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THE COMMISSION AN INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION AS A
RECOMMENDATION. THAT THEY COUNT
PEOPLE IN THEIR LAST HOME
ADDRESS AND THEY HAVE FOUND THAT
IT WAS SUCCESSFUL IT WAS
IMPORTANT THERE WERE NO
CHALLENGES TO THE NEW MAPS THAT
WERE DRAWN. I AND THEN THEY ARE
THEY HAVE SUPPORTED THE IDEA OF
DOING THAT PERMANENTLY- IN
ADDITION TO THIS LEGISLATOR
MOVING PREVIOUS LEGISLATION BACK
ON THE LEGISLATURE HAD THE POWER
TO DRAW THESE LINES AND SO I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
THE CAN COMMISSION CONSISTENT
WITH THE HISTORY OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND- IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF- ADEQUATE AND
APPROPRIATE REPRESENTATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ALL
RIGHT. SO I THINK WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECONDARY SAID THAT. GO
AHEAD IN- CULTURAL. IF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN HI. BRIAN I
SEYARTO SEYARTO NO BENNETT HI
SENATE I. LO I MAYES LEAVE. WE
ARE BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I. THAT MEASURE IS OUT FIVE TO
ONE. IT'S PAST WEAR- CREATION
THAT DO PASSED THE POPE. WE HAVE
ONE ON- IT DOESN'T. I TO AB SIX
SO. MEDITATOR WE CALL THE ROLL-
ON SIXTEENTH THE MOST IS TO PAY
IN BE RE REFER THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN. NO BRIAN
NO SEYARTO SEYARTO I MAYES.
THREE THE MEASURE FAILS. WELL WE
HAVE PROBLEM OF THE NIGHT ADAM
ALL OF THEM IN A SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL FOR ADULTS. ON THE-
CALENDAR THAT'S EIGHTY SIXTEEN
THIRTY ONE CERVANTES AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BIGELOW AND
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN TO
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS- BRIAN.
BRIAN I SEYARTO BY SEYARTO I
MAYES. ON ITEM THREE ABC
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SEYARTO. NO
SEYARTO NO MAYES. ON ITEM FOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOMEONE MEMBER LEVINE
MOTIONS TO PASS AND BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SEYARTO HI
SEYARTO I MAYES. ON ITEM FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON A PROBE SEYARTO SEYARTO NO
MAYES. I AM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND BE REFERRED COMING
OUT OF PROBES MAYES. ON ITEM
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BRIAN. BRIAN I SEYARTO
YEAH SEYARTO NO MAYES. PAGE.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE. TWO ONE
SIX TWO THREE THREE AUTHORED
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT ON RIGHT GO
TO PRESENTATION ABOUT OKAY.
THREE THINGS. AND THAT CONCLUDES
TODAY'S ELECTIONS THANK YOU.